remember george washington you know how
he died well-meaning physicians bled him
to death and this was the most important
patient
in the country
maybe in the history of the country
and it's and we bled him to death trying
to help him
so when you're actually inflating the
money supply at seven percent but you're
calling it two percent because you want
to help the economy
you're literally bleeding
the the free market to death
but the sad fact is george washington
went along with it
because he thought that they were going
to do him good
and
the majority of of uh the society most
companies
most most conventional thinkers
you know
the working class
they go along with this because they
think that someone has their best
interest in mind and the people that are
bleeding them to death
believe
they they believe that prescription
because their mental models are just so
defective
the following is a conversation with
michael saylor one of the most prominent
and brilliant bitcoin proponents in the
world
he is the ceo of microstrategy
founder of sailor academy graduate of
mit
and michael is one of the most
fascinating and rigorous thinkers i've
ever gotten a chance to explore ideas
with he can effortlessly zoom out to the
big perspectives of human civilization
in human history and zoom back in to the
technical details of blockchains markets
governments and financial systems
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's michael
saylor
let's start with a big question of truth
and wisdom
when advanced humans or aliens or ai
systems let's say five to ten centuries
from now look back at earth
on this early 21st century
how much do you think they would say we
understood about
money and economics or even about
engineering science life death meaning
intelligence consciousness all the big
interesting questions
i think they would uh
probably give us a
b minus on engineering on all the
engineering things the hard sciences the
passing grade
like we're doing okay we're working our
way through rockets and jets and
electric cars and uh
electricity transport systems and
nuclear power and space flight
and the like
and you know if you if you look at the
walls
that uh grace the great court at mit
it's full of all the great thinkers and
and they're all pretty admirable you
know if you could be with newton or
gauss or
madame curie or
einstein
you know you would respect them
i would say they'd give us like a
a d minus on economics
like
you know an f plus or a d minus you you
have an optimistic vision first of all
optimistic vision of engineering
because everybody you've listed
not everybody most people you've listed
is just over the past couple of
centuries
and maybe it stretches a little farther
back but mostly
all the cool stuff we've done in
engineering is the past couple centuries
i mean archimedes
you know had his virtues
you know i studied the history of
science at mit and i also studied
aerospace engineering and and so i
clearly have a bias in favor of science
and if i look at the past 10 000 years
and i consider
all of the philosophy and the politics
and their impact on the human condition
i think it's a wash for every politician
that came up with a good idea another
politician came up with a bad idea yeah
right and it's not clear to me that you
know most of the political and
philosophical you know
contributions to the to the human race
and the human conditions have advanced
so much i mean we're still taking
you know taking guidance and admiring
aristotle and plato and seneca and the
like
and on the other hand
you know if you think about uh what has
made the human condition better
fire
water harnessing of wind energy like try
to row across an ocean
right not easy and for people who are
just listening or watching there's a
beautiful sexy ship from
16
century this is a 19th century handmade
model of a 17th century
sailing ship which is of the type that
the dutch east india's company used to
sail the world and trade so that was
made you know the original was made
sometime in the 1600s and then this
model is made in the 19th
century by individuals both the model
and the ship itself is engineering at
its best and just imagine just like
raucous flying out to space how much
hope this filled people with exploring
the unknown going into the mystery
uh
both the entrepreneurs and the business
people and the engineers and just humans
what's out there what's out there to be
discovered yeah the metaphor of human
beings leaving shore or sailing across
the horizon risking their lives in
pursuit of a better life is an
incredibly powerful one
in
1900 i suppose the average life
expectancy is 50.
during the revolutionary war you know
while our founding fathers were fighting
to establish you know life liberty
pursuit of happiness the constitution
average life expectancy of it's like 32.
some between 32 and 36.
so all the sound in the fury doesn't
make you live past 32 but what does
right antibiotics
conquest of infectious diseases if we
understand the science of
of infectious disease they're you know
sterilizing
a knife
and harnessing antibiotics gets you from
50 to 70 and that happened fast right
that happens from 1900 to 1950 or
something like that
and i i think if you look
look at the human condition
you ever get on one of those rowing
machines where they actually keep track
of your watts output when you're on that
yeah you know it's like 200 is a lot
okay 200
is a lot so a kilowatt hour
is like all the energy that a human a
trained athlete can deliver in
a day
and probably not one percent of the
people in the in the world could deliver
a kilowatt hour in a day and the
commercial value of a kilowatt hour the
retail value is 11 cents today and uh
the wholesale value is two cents
and
so you have to look at the contribution
of politicians and philosophers and
economists to the human condition
and and it's it's like at best to wash
one way or the other and then if you
look at the contribution of john d
rockefeller
when he delivered you a barrel of oil
yeah and then you know the energy and in
oil liquid energy or the contribution of
tesla
you know as we deliver electricity
you know
and what's the impact of the human
condition if i have
electric power
if i have chemical power if i have wind
energy
if i if i can actually set up a
reservoir create a dam spin a turbine
and generate energy from a hydraulic
source
that's extraordinary
right and and so our ability to cross
the ocean
our ability to grow food our ability to
live
it's it's technology that gets the human
race from
you know
a brutal life where life expectancy is
30
to
a world where life expectancy is 80.
you gave a d minus the economist so are
they two like the politicians awash
in terms of there's good ideas and bad
ideas and and that tiny delta between
good and
and bad is how you squeak past the f
plus onto the d minus territory
i think most economic ideas are bad
ideas like most
you know like um
take us back to mit and you want to
solve uh a fluid dynamics problem like
like design the shape of the whole of
that ship
or you want to design an airfoil a wing
or if you want to design
an engine or a
a nozzle and a rocket ship
you wouldn't do it with simple
arithmetic
you wouldn't do it with a scalar there's
not a single number right is vector it's
vector math you know computational fluid
dynamics is n dimensional
higher level math you know complicated
stuff
so when when an economist says the
inflation rate is two percent that's a
scalar and when an economist says
it's not a problem to print more money
because the velocity of the money is
very low the monetary velocity is low
that's another scalar
okay so
the truth of the matter is
inflation is not a scalar inflation is
an in-dimensional vector
money velocity is not a scalar
um
develo saying what's the velocity of
money oh oh it's slow or it's fast
it ignores the question of
what medium is the money moving through
in the same way that you know
what's the speed of sound
okay well what is sound right
sound you know sound is uh is a
compression wave it's energy uh moving
through a medium but the speed is
different
so for example the speed of sound
through air is different than the speed
of sound through water
and and a sound moves faster through
water it moves faster through a solid
and it moves faster to a stiffer solid
so there isn't one
what is the fundamental problem with the
way economists reduce the world down to
a model is it too simple
or is it just even the first principles
of constructing the model is wrong i
think that uh the fundamental problem is
if you see the world as a scalar you
simply pick
the one number which is
which supports whatever you want to do
and you ignore
the universe of other
consequences from your behavior
in general i don't know if you've heard
of
like eric watson has been talking about
this with gage theory so different
different kinds of approaches
from the physics world from the
mathematical world to
extend past this
scalar view of economics so gauge theory
is one way that comes from physics
do you find that
a way of exploring economics interesting
so outside of cryptocurrency outside of
the actual technologies and so on just
analysis of how economics works do you
find that interesting
yeah i i think that if we're going to
want to really make any scientific
progress in economics we have to apply
much
much more computationally intensive and
richer forms of mathematics
so simulation perhaps or
yeah you know when i was at mit i
studied system dynamics
you know they taught it at the sloan
school it was developed by jay forrester
who
who
who
was an extraordinary computer scientist
and
when we've created models
of
economic behavior they were all
multi-dimensional non-linear models so
if you want to describe how
anything works in the real world you
have to start with the concept of
feedback
if i double the price of something
demand will fall and attempts to
to create supply will increase and there
will be a delay
before the capacity increases there'll
be an instant demand
change and there'll be rippling effects
throughout every other segment of the
economy downstream and upstream of such
thing
so it's kind of common sense
but most economics most classical
economics it's always
you know taught with linear models
you know fairly simplistic linear models
and oftentimes even i'm really shocked
today
that the entire
mainstream dialogue of economics has
been captured by
scalar arithmetic
for example
if if you read
you know read any article in new york
times or the wall street journal right
they just refer to there's an inflation
number or the the cpi or
the inflation rate is x
and if you look at all the historic
studies
of the impact of inflation
generally they're all based upon
the idea that inflation equals cpi and
then they try to extrapolate from that
and you just get nowhere with it
so
at the very least we should be
considering inflation and other
economics concept as a non-linear
dynamical system so non-linearity and
also just embracing the full complexity
of just how the variables interact maybe
through simulation maybe some have some
interesting models around that wouldn't
it be refreshing if somebody for once
published a table of the change in price
of every product every service and every
asset in every place
over time
you said table some of that also is the
task of visualization
how to extract from this complex set of
numbers
patterns that
uh somehow indicate something
fundamental about what's happening so
like each summarization of data is still
important perhaps summarization not down
to a single scalar value but looking at
that whole sea of numbers you have to
find
patterns like what is inflation in a
particular sector what is maybe uh
change over time maybe different
geographical regions
you know
things of that nature i think that's
kind of i don't know even what that task
is uh you know that's what you could
look at machine learning you can look at
ai with that perspective which is like
how do you represent
what's happening efficiently
as efficiently as possible that's never
going to be a single number but it might
be a compressed model that captures
something
something beautiful something
fundamental about what's happening
it's an opportunity
for sure
right um
you know
if we take um for example during the
pandemic
the
the response of the political apparatus
was to lower interest rates to zero
and to start to
start buying assets in essence printing
money
and the defense was there's no inflation
yeah
but of course you had one part of the
economy where it was locked down so it
was illegal to buy anything
but you couldn't you know it was either
illegal or it was impractical
so it would be impossible for demand to
manifest so of course there is no
inflation
on the other hand
there was instantaneous immediate
inflation in another part of the economy
for example um
you lowered the interest rates uh to
zero one point we saw the uh the swap
rate on the 30-year note go to 72 basis
points
okay that means that the value of a long
dated bond immediately inflates so the
bond market had hyper inflation within
minutes
of these
financial decisions the asset market had
hyperinflation
we had
what you call a case shape recovery what
we affectionately call a shake k shape
recovery main street shutdown
wall street recovered all within six
weeks
the inflation was in the assets
like in the stocks in the bonds uh
you know if you look today you see that
a
typical house according to case-shiller
index today is up 19.2 percent
year-over-year
so
if you're a first-time home buyer the
inflation rate is 19 percent
uh the formal cpi announced a 7.9
percent
you can pretty much
create any inflation rate you want by
constructing a market basket a weighted
basket of products or services or assets
that yield you the answer
i think that
you know the fundamental failing of
economist is is first of all
they don't really have a term for asset
inflation
right what's an asset what's asset
hyperinflation you mentioned bond market
swap rate and asset is where the all
majority of the hyperinflation happened
what's inflation what's hyperinflation
what's an asset what's an asset market
i'm going to ask so many dumb questions
in the conventional economic world you
would you would treat inflation as uh
the rate of increase in price of a
market basket of consumer products
defined by a government agency
so they have a like traditional things
that a regular consumer would be buying
the government selects like toilet paper
food
toaster
refrigerator electronics all that kind
of stuff and it's like a representative
a basket of goods
that lead to a content existence on this
earth for a regular consumer they define
a synthetic metric right i mean i i'm
going to say you should have a thousand
square foot apartment and you should
have
a used car and you should eat you know
three hamburgers a week
now ten years go by and the apartment
costs more
i could adjust the market basket
by a you know they call them hedonic
adjustments i could decide that it used
to be in 1970 to a thousand square feet
but in the year 2020 you only need 700
square feet because we've many
miniaturized televisions
and we've got more efficient electric
appliances and because things have
collapsed into the iphone you just don't
need as much space
so now i you know it may be that the
apartment costs 50 percent more but
after the hedonic adjustment there is no
inflation because i just downgraded the
expectation of what a normal person
should have so the synthetic nature of
the metric allows for manipulation
by people in power
pretty much
i guess my criticism of economist is
rather than embracing inflation
based upon its fundamental idea which is
the rate at which the price of things go
up
right
they've been captured
by a
mainstream conventional thinking to
immediately equate inflation to
the government issued cpi or
government-issued pce or
government-issued ppi measure which
was never the rate at which things go up
it's simply the rate at which a
synthetic basket of
products and services the government
wishes to track go up
now the problem with that
is is
two big things one thing is the
government gets to create the market
basket and so they keep changing what's
in the basket
over time
so i mean if
if i keep tr if i said three years ago
you should go see ten concerts a year
and the concert tickets now cost two
hundred dollars each now it's two
thousand dollars a year to go see
concerts
now i'm in charge of calculating
inflation so i redefine you know your
entertainment quota for the year to be
eight netflix streaming concerts and now
they don't cost two thousand dollars
they cost nothing and there is no
inflation but you don't get your
concerts right so the problem starts
with
continually changing the definition of
the market basket but in my opinion
that's not the biggest problem
the more
the more egregious problem
is the the fundamental idea that assets
aren't products or services
assets can't be inflated with an asset a
house
a share of apple stock
um a bond
um any a bitcoin is an asset um or uh a
picasso painting so
not a consumable good
not a uh not not an apple that you can
eat
right if i throw away an asset
then uh i'm not on the hook to track the
inflation rate for it so
what happens if i change the policy such
that
let's take the class example a million
dollar bond at a five percent interest
rate gives you fifty thousand dollars a
year in risk-free income
you might retire on fifty thousand
dollars a year in a low-cost
jurisdiction
so the cost of social security or early
retirement is one million dollars when
the interest rate is five percent
uh during the the crisis of march of
2020 the interest rate went on a 10-year
bond went to 50 basis points
okay so now the cost of that bond is 10
million dollars
okay the cost of social security went
from a million dollars to 10 million
dollars
so if you wanted to work your entire
life save money and then retire
risk-free and live happily ever after on
a 50 000 salary living on a beach in
mexico wherever you wanted to go
you had hyperinflation the cost of your
aspiration increased by a factor of 10
over the course of
you know some amount of time in fact
in that case that was like over the
course of about 12 years
right as the inflation rate ground down
the asset traded up
but the you know the conventional view
is oh that's not a problem because it's
good that that assets it's good that the
bond is highly priced because we own the
bond
or um
what's the problem with the inflation
rate in housing being 19
it's an awful problem for a 22 year old
that's starting their first job that's
saving money to buy a house
but it would be characterized as a
benefit to society by a conventional
economist who would say well
housing
asset values are higher because of
interest rate fluctuation and now the
economy's got more wealth
and uh and so that's that's viewed as a
benefit
so the what's being missed here
like the suffering of the average person
or the
uh the struggle the suffering the pain
of the average person
like metrics that captured that within
the economic system is that is it when
you talk about one way to say it is a
conventional
view of inflation as cpi understates the
human misery that's in inflicted upon
the working class
and and on uh mainstream companies
uh
by uh
by the political class and so it's a
massive shift of wealth from the working
class to the property class
it's a massive shift of power from the
free market uh to the centrally governed
or the controlled market
it's a massive shift of power from the
people to the government and and
maybe one one more illustrative point
here alexis
is uh what do you think the inflation
rate's been for the past 100 years
oh you talking about the scalar again if
you if you took a survey of everybody on
the street and you asked them what do
they think inflation was uh what is it
you know
remember when jerome powell said our
target's two percent but we're not there
if you go
around the corner i have uh posted the
deed to this house sold in 1930.
okay and uh
the number on that deed is one hundred
thousand dollars
1930. and if you go on zillow
and you get the z estimate is it higher
than that no 30 million 500 000
yeah
so
that's uh 92 years 1930 or
2022
and
and in 92 years we've had 305
x increase in price of the house
now if you actually back calculate you
can you come to a conclusion that the
inflation rate was approximately six and
a half percent a year
every year
for 92 years
okay and and there's nobody
nobody in government no conventional
economist that would ever admit to an
inflation rate of seven percent a year
in the us dollar over the last century
now
if you if you uh dig deeper i mean one
one guy that's done a great job working
on this is seifidin amus who wrote who
wrote the book the bitcoin standard and
he notes that on average it looks like
the inflation rate and the money supply
is about seven percent a year all the
way up to the year 2020
if you look at the s p index which is a
market basket of scarce desirable stocks
it returned about 10 percent
if you talk to 10 a year for 100 years
the money supply is expanding at 7 100
years
if you actually talk to economists or
you look at the the economy and you ask
the question how fast does the economy
grow
in its entirety year over year
generally about two to three percent
like the sum total impact of all this
technology and human ingenuity
might get you a two and a half three
percent improvement a year as measured
by gdp
is that are you okay with that not sure
i'm not sure i'd go that far yet but i
would just say that
if you had the human race doing stuff
yeah and if you ask the question how
much more efficiently will we do the
stuff next year than this year or how
what's the value of all of our
innovations and inventions and
investments in the past 12 months
you'd be hard-pressed to say we get two
percent better
typical investor thinks they they're 10
better every year
so if you look at what's going on really
when you're holding a million dollars of
stocks and you're getting a 10 gain a
year you really get a seven percent
expansion of the money supply
you're getting a two or three percent
gain under best circumstances
and
another way to say that is
if the money supply stopped expanding at
seven percent a year the s p yield might
be three percent and not ten percent it
probably should be
now that that gets you to start to ask a
bunch of other fundamental questions
like if i borrow a billion dollars and
pay three percent interest and the money
supply expands at seven to ten percent a
year and
i ended up making a ten percent return
on a you know billion dollar investment
paying three percent interest is that
fair
and who who suffered
so that i could do that because
in an environment where you're just
inflating the money supply and you're
holding the assets constant
it stands the reason that the price of
all the assets is going to appreciate
somewhat proportional to the money
supply
and the difference in asset
appreciations is going to be a function
of the scarce desirable quality of the
assets and to what extent can i make
more of them and to what extent are they
are they truly limited in supply
yeah so we'll we'll get to a lot of the
words you said there the scarcity
uh and it's so good connected to how
limited they are and the value of those
assets but you also said so the
expansion of the money supply you just
put another way is printing money and so
is is that always bad the expansion of
the money supply is this just uh to put
some terms on the table so we understand
them
um
you nonchalantly say it's always
the on average expanding every year the
money supply is expanding every year by
seven percent that's a bad thing that's
a universally bad thing
it's awful
well i guess i guess to be precise
uh it's the currency
that i mean
my money uh i would say money is
monetary energy or economic energy
and the economic energy has to find its
way into a medium so if you want to move
it rapidly as a medium of exchange has
to find its way into currency but the
money can also flow into property like a
house or gold
if the money flows into property
it'll probably
hold its value much better if the money
flows into currency right if you had put
a hundred thousand dollars in this house
you would have 305 x return over 92
years but if you had put the money a
hundred thousand dollars in a safe
deposit box and buried it in the
basement
you would have lost 99.7
percent of your wealth over the same
time period
so um so the the expansion of the
currency
creates uh creates a massive
inefficiency in the society what i'll
call an adiabatic lapse
it's
what we're doing is we're bleeding
the civilization to death right the
antibiotic adiabatic what's that word
that's
adiabatic adiabatic
right and aerospace engineering you want
to solve any problem they they start
with the phrase assume an adiabatic
system and what that means is a closed
system okay so i've got it i've got a
container and in that container no air
leaves and no air enters no energy exits
or enters so it's a closed system
so you got the closed system lapse
okay
okay i'm going to use a there's a leak
in the ship i'm going to use a physical
metaphor for you because you're the
jujitsu right like like you got 10 pints
of blood in your body
and so before your next
workout i'm going to take one pint from
you
now you're going to go exercise but
you're one point you've lost 10 percent
of your blood
okay
you're not going to perform as well it
takes about one month for your body to
replace the red blood platelets so what
if i tell you every month you got to
show up and i'm going to bleed you
yeah okay so uh so if i'm draining the
energy i'm drink i'm draining the blood
from your body you can't perform
if you adiabatic lapse is when you go up
in altitude every thousand feet you lose
three degrees
you go 50 000 feet you're 150 degrees
colder than sea level that's why you you
know you look at your
instruments and instead of 80 degrees
your minus 70 degrees
why is the temperature falling
temperatures falling because it's not a
closed system it's an open system as the
air expands the density falls
right the ener
the energy
per
uh
per cubic whatever you know falls and
therefore the temperature falls right
the heat's falling out of the solution
so
when you're inflating let's say you're
inflating the money so the currency
supply by six percent you're sucking six
percent of the energy
out of the fluid that the economy is
using to function so the currency this
kind of ocean of currency that's a nice
way for the economy to function it's the
most kind of uh
it's being inefficient when you expand
the money supply but it's uh
that look it's the liquid i'm trying to
find the right kind of adjective here
it's how you do transactions at a scale
of billions
currency is the asset we use uh to move
monetary energy around and you could use
the dollar or you could use the peso or
you could use the bolivar selling houses
and buying houses is much more
inefficient
or like
you can't
transact between billions of people with
houses yeah properties don't make such
good mediums of exchange they make
better stores of value and they they
have utility value if it's a if it's a
ship or a house or or a plane or a
bushel of corn
right
can i zoom out just for yeah can we zoom
out keep zooming out until we reach the
origin of human civilization but on the
way
ask
you gave economists a d-minus
i'm not even going to ask you what you
give to governments
uh
do you think their failure economist and
government failure is malevolence or
incompetence
i think uh
policymakers are well-intentioned but
generally all all government policy is
inflationary and all government it's
inflammatory and inflationary so what i
mean by that is
you know when you have a policy uh
pursuing
uh
supply chain independence if you have an
energy policy if you have a labor policy
if you have a trade policy if you have a
you know any any kind of foreign policy
a domestic policy
a manufacturing policy every one of
these medical policy
every one of these policies
interferes with the free market and and
generally prevents some rational actor
from doing it in a cheaper more
efficient way
so when you layer them
on top of each other they all have to be
paid for
if you want to shut down the entire
economy for a year you have to pay for
it right if you want to fight a war you
have to pay for it
right if you don't want to use oil or
natural gas you have to pay for it if
you don't want to manufacture
semiconductors in china and you want to
manufacture them in the u.s you got to
pay for it if i rebuild the entire
supply chain in pennsylvania and i hire
a bunch of employees and then i unionize
the employees
then not only am i
i idle the factory in the far east it
goes to 50 capacity so so whatever it
sells it has to raise the price on and
then i drive up the cost of labor for
every other manufacturer in the us
because i competing against them
right i'm changing their conditions so
everything gets less efficient
everything gets more expensive and of
course the government couldn't really
pay for
uh its policies and its wars with taxes
we didn't pay for world war one with tax
we didn't pay for world war ii with tax
we didn't pay for vietnam with tax in
fact you know when you trace this what
you realize is the government never pays
for all of its policies with taxes
to ask to raise the taxes to truly
transparently pay for the things you're
doing with taxes with taxpayer money
because they feel that's one
interpretation or it's just too
transparent like if people if people
understood the the the true cost of war
they wouldn't want to go to war if you
were told that you would lose 95 of your
assets you know and 90 of everything you
will be ever will be taken from you
you might
reprioritize your thought about a given
policy and you might not vote for that
politician but you're still saying
incompetence not malevolence
so fundamentally government creates a
bureaucracy of incompetence is kind of
how you look at it
i think a lack of humility right
like uh like
if if people had more humility then they
would realize
humility about how little they know
how little they understand about the
function of complexity this is the
phrase from queen eastwood's movie
unforgiven where he says a man's got to
know his limitations
[Laughter]
i i think that a lot of people
overestimate
what they can accomplish and experience
experience in life causes you
to uh
to reevaluate that so i mean i've done a
lot of things in my life and and
generally
my mistakes were always my good ideas
that i enthusiastically pursued
to the detriment of my
great ideas that required
150 of my attention
to prosper so i think people pursue too
many good ideas and you know they all
sound good
but there's just a limit to to what you
can accomplish
and everybody underestimates the
challenges
of of implementing an idea
right and uh and they always
overestimate the benefits
of the pursuit of that so i think it's
an overconfidence that causes an over
exuberance and pursuit of policies and
as the ambition of the government
expands so must the currency supply
you know i could say the money survival
let's say the currency supply
um
you can triple the number of pesos in
the economy
but it doesn't triple uh the amount of
manufacturing capacity in the said
economy
and it doesn't triple the amount of
assets in the economy it just triples
the pesos so as you
increase the currency supply
then the price of all those scarce
desirable things will tend to go up
rapidly
and the confidence
of
all of the institutions the corporations
and the individual actors
and trading partners will will collapse
if we take a tangent on a tangent and we
will
return soon to the uh the big human
civilization question
uh
so if government
naturally wants to buy stuff it can't
afford
what's the best form of government
uh anarchism
libertarianism so not even go there's
not even armies there's no
borders that's anarchism the least
the smallest possible
the smallest possible the last the best
government would be the least and the
debate will be over
that when you think about the stuff
do you think about okay government is
the way it is i
as a person that can generate great
ideas how do i operate in this world or
do you also think about the big picture
if we start a new
civilization somewhere on mars do you
think about what's the ultimate form of
government
what's uh at least a promising thing to
try
you know um
i have laser eyes on my profile on
twitter
what does that mean and the significance
of laser eyes is to focus on the thing
that can make a difference yes and um
if i look at the civilization
um i would say
half the problems in the civilization
are due to the fact that our
understanding of economics and money is
defective
half
50
i don't know it's worth 500 trillion
dollars worth of problems like
money uh money represents all the
economic energy and the civilization and
it kind of equates to all the products
all the services and all the assets that
we have and we're ever gonna have so
that's half
the other half of the problems in the
civilization are medical
and
and military and political
and philosophical
and you know
and uh
and i think that there are a lot of
different solutions
to all those problems and they're all
they are all uh
honorable professions and
and they all merit a lifetime of
consideration for the specialist in all
those areas
i i think that
what i could offer it's constructive is
inflation is completely misunderstood
it's a much bigger problem
than we understand it to be
we need to introduce engineering and
science techniques into economics if we
want to further the human condition
all government policy is inflationary
you know and another pernicious myth
is uh inflation is always
and everywhere a monetary phenomena so
you know a famous quote by milton
friedman i believe it's like it's a
monetary phenomena that is inflation
comes from expanding the currency supply
it's a nice phrase
and it's oftentimes quoted by people
that are anti-inflation
but again it it just signifies a lack of
appreciation of what the issue is
inflation is if i if i had a currency
which was completely
non-inflationary if if i never printed
another dollar
and if i eliminated fractional reserve
banking from the face of the earth
we'd still have inflation and we'd have
inflation as long as we have government
that that is capable of pursuing
any kind of policies that are in the in
themselves inflationary and generally
they all are so in general
inflationary is the big
characteristic of human nature that
governments collection of groups that
have power over others and allocate
other people's resources
will
try to
intentionally or not hide the costs of
those
allocations like in some tricky ways
whatever the options ever available
you know hiding the cost is like is like
the
the tertiary thing like
the the primary goal is the government
will attempt to do good
right and that's the fundament that's
the primary problem they will attempt to
do good and they will and they will do
it and they will do good and imperfectly
and they will create
oftentimes uh as much damage
more damage than the good they do most
government policy will be iatrogenic it
will it will create more harm than good
in the pursuit of it but it is what it
is the secondary
uh the secondary issue is they will
unintentionally pay for it by expanding
the currency supply without realizing
that they're uh
they're actually paying for it in
in a sub-optimal fashion they'll
collapse their own currencies while they
attempt to do good the the tertiary
issue is they will mismeasure
how badly they're collapsing the
currency
so for example if you go to the bureau
of labor statistics you know and look at
the numbers printed by the fed they'll
say oh it looks like the dollar has lost
95 of its purchasing power over 100
years okay they sort of fess up there's
a problem but they make it 95 percent
loss over 100 years what they don't do
is
realize it's a 99.7
loss over 80 years so they will
mismeasure just the horrific extent
of uh the monetary policy in pursuit of
the foreign policy and the domestic
policy which they
they they
overestimate their budget
and their means to accomplish their ends
and they underestimate the cost
and and they're oblivious to the
horrific
damage that they do to the civilization
because
the mental models that they use that are
conventionally taught
are wrong right the mental model that
like it's okay we can print all this
money because the velocity of the money
is low right because money velocity is a
scalar and inflation is the scalar and
we don't see two percent inflation yet
and the money velocity is low and so
it's okay if we print
trillions of dollars well
the money velocity was immediate
right the velocity of money through the
crypto economy
is 10 000 times faster
than the velocity of money through the
consumer economy
right it's like i think nick pointed out
when you spoke to him he said it takes
two months for a credit card transaction
to settle
right so you want to spend a million
dollars in the consumer economy you can
move it six times a year
you you put a million dollars into gold
gold will sit in a vault for a decade
okay so the velocity of money through
gold is 0.1
you put the money in the stock market
and you can trade it once a week the
settlement is t plus 2 maybe you get to
two to one leverage you might get to a
money velocity of a hundred a year
in the stock market
you put your money into the crypto
economy and these people are settling
every four hours
and and you know if you're offshore
they're trading with 20x leverage
so if you if you settle every day
and you trade the 20x leverage you just
went to 7 000.
yeah so the la the velocity of the money
varies i think the politicians they they
don't really understand inflation and
they don't understand economics but but
you can't blame them
because the economists don't understand
economics because the because if they
did
they would be creating
multi-variate computer simulations where
they actually put in
the price
of every piece of housing in every city
in the world the full array of foods and
the full array of products and the full
array of assets
and then
on a monthly basis they would publish
all those results and where and that's a
high bandwidth
requirement
and i i think that people don't really
want to embrace it
and and also there's the most pernicious
thing
there's that phrase
you know
you can't
tell people what to think but you can
tell them what to think about the most
pernicious thing
is is i get you to misunderstand
the phenomena
so that even when it's happening to you
you don't appreciate that it's a bad
thing and you think it's a good thing so
if housing prices are going up 20
percent year over year and i say this is
great for the american public because
most most of them are home owners
then i have i've misrepresented a
phenomena inflation is 20
not 7 percent and then i've
misrepresented it as being a positive
rather than a negative
and people will stare at it and you
could even show them their house on fire
and they would perceive it as being
great because it's warming them up and
they're going to save on their heat
costs it does seem that the cruder the
model whether it's economics whether
it's psychology
the easier it is to weave whatever the
heck narrative you want
and not in a malicious way but just like
it's it's some some kind of like uh
emergent phenomena this narrative thing
that we tell ourselves so you can tell
any kind of story about inflation
inflation is good inflation is bad like
the cruder the model the easier it is to
tell a narrative about it and that's
what the so like if you take an
engineering approach
it's i feel like it becomes more and
more difficult
to run away from sort of a true deep
understanding
of the dynamics of the system
i mean honestly if you went to 100
people on the street you asked them to
define inflation how many would how many
would say
it's a vector tracking the change in
price
of every product service asset in the
world over time
no not me
no
if you if you went to them and you said
you know do you think two percent
inflation a year is good or bad
the majority would probably say well
here it's good you know the majority of
economists would say
two percent inflation a year is good
and of course there's
look at the ship next to us what if i
told you
that
the ship leaked
two percent right
of its volume every something right the
ship is rotting two percent a year that
means the useful life of the ship is 50
years now ironically that's true like a
wooden ship had a 50
year to 100 year life 100b long 50 years
not unlikely so when we built ships out
of wood
they had a useful life of about 50 years
and then they sunk they rotted there's
nothing good about it right you build a
ship out of steel
you know and it's zero as opposed to two
percent degradation
and how much better is zero percent
versus two percent
well
two percent means you have a useful life
of
you know
it's half-life of 35 years
2 2 is a half-life of 35 years that's
basically the half-life of money in gold
if i store your life force in gold under
perfect circumstances you have a useful
life at 35 years
zero percent is a useful life of forever
so zero percent is immortal
two percent is 35 years average life
expectancy
so that the idea that you would think
the life expectancy of the currency and
the civilization should be 35 years
instead of forever is is kind of a silly
notion but the tragic notion is
it was it was you know
seven into seventy or ten years
it's the money has had a half-life of
ten years except for the fact that
in weak societies in in
argentina or the like the half-life of
the money is
three to four years in venezuela one
year
so
the united states dollar
and the united states economic system
was the most successful economic system
in the last hundred years in the world
we won every war we were the world
superpower our currency lost 99.7
percent of its value and that means
horrifically every other currency
lost everything right in essence the the
other ones were 99.9 except for most
that were 100 because they all
completely failed
and uh
you know you've got a you've got a
mainstream economic community you know
that thinks that
inflation is a number and two percent is
desirable
it's it's it's kind of like
you know remember george washington you
know how he died no
well-meaning physicians bled him to
death
okay the last thing in the world you
would want to do to a sick person is
bleed them right in the modern world i
think we understand that that oxygen is
carried by the blood cells and
and
you know
and
if uh
you know there's that phrase right uh a
triage phrase what's the first thing you
do in an injury
stop the bleeding
single first thing right you show up
after any action i look at you stop the
bleeding because you're going to be dead
in a matter of minutes if you bleed out
so
it strikes me as being ironic that
orthodox conventional wisdom was bleed
the patient to death and this was the
most important patient
in the country
maybe in the history of the country
and it's and we bled him to death trying
to help him so when you're actually
inflating the money supply at seven
percent but you're calling it two
percent because you want to help the
economy
you're literally bleeding
the the free market to death but the sad
fact is george washington went along
with it
because he thought that they were going
to do him good
and
the majority of of uh the society most
companies
most most conventional thinkers
you know
the working class they go along with
this because they think that someone has
their best interest in mind and the
people that are bleeding them to death
believe
they they believe that prescription
because their mental models are just so
defective and their understanding of
energy
and engineering and
and uh and the economics that are at
play
is uh is crippled by these mental models
but that's both the bug and the feature
of human civilization that ideas take
hold they unite us we believe in them
uh
and we make a lot of cool stuff happen
by
as an average sort of just the fact of
the matter
a lot of people believe the same thing
they get together and they get some [ __ ]
done because they believe that thing and
then some ideas can be really bad and
really destructive but on average the
ideas seem to be progressing
in in a direction of good let me just
step back
what the hell are we doing here us
humans on this earth
how do you think of humans how special
are humans
how did human civilization
originate on this earth
and what is this human project that
we're all taking on
you mentioned
fire and water and apparently bleeding
you to death is not a good idea i
thought always thought you can get the
demons out in that way but
um that was a recent
invention so what what's this thing
we're doing here
i think what distinguishes uh human
beings from all the other creatures on
the earth is
is
our ability to engineer
we're engineers
right to solve problems or just
build incredible cool things
engineering
harnessing energy and technique to make
the world a better place than you found
it
right from the point that we actually
started to play with fire
right that was a big leap forward
uh harnessing the power of of kinetic
energy and missiles another another step
forward
every city built on water why water well
water's
bringing energy right if you actually
if you actually put a turbine you know
on a river or you uh
or you capture a change in elevation of
water you've literally harnessed
gravitational energy but you know water
is also bringing you food it's also
giving you you know
a cheap form of uh getting rid of your
waste it's also giving you free
transportation you want to move one ton
blocks around you want to move them in
water so
i think i mean the the the human story
is really the story of engineering a
better world
and and uh the rise in the human
condition is determined by those uh
groups of people those civilizations
that were best at harnessing energy
right if you if you look
you know the greek civilization they
built it around around ports and
seaports and and water and created a
trading network
the romans were really good at
harnessing all sorts of
of engineering i mean the aqueducts are
a great example
if you go to any big city
you travel through cities in the med you
find that you know the carrying capacity
of the city or the island is 5 000
people without running water and then if
you can find a way to bring water to it
increases by a factor of 10
and so
human flourishing is really only
possible through that channeling of
energy
right that eventually takes the
the form of
air power right i mean
that ship
i mean look at the intricacy of those
sales
right i mean it's
just the model is intricate now think
about all of the experimentation that
took place to figure out how many sales
to put on that ship and how to rig them
and how to repair them and
how to operate them
there's thousands of lives
spent thinking through all the tiny
little details
all to increase the efficiency of this
the effectiveness the efficiency of this
ship
as it sails through water
and we should also note there's a bunch
of cannons on the side so obviously
another form of en engineering right
energy harnessing with
explosives to achieve what end that's
another discussion exactly
suppose we're trying to get off the
planet right i mean well there's a
selection mechanism going on so natural
selection this whatever however
evolution works it seems that one of the
interesting inventions on earth was the
predator prey dynamic
that you want to be the bigger fish
that violence seems to serve a useful
purpose if you look at earth as a whole
we as humans
now
like to think of violence as really a
bad thing
it seems to be one of the
amazing things about humans is we're
ultimately tend towards cooperation we
want to we like peace
uh if you just look at history we want
things to be nice and calm
and
um
but just wars break out every once in a
while and lead to immense suffering and
destruction and so on and they have a
kind of
uh like resetting the palette
effect it's it's one that's full of just
immeasurable human suffering but it's
like a way to start over
we're called the apex predator on the
planet
and i i googled something the other day
you know what's the most common form of
mammal
life on earth
by by number of organisms count by count
and the answer that came back was human
beings
i was shocked i couldn't believe it
right it says like
apparently if we're just looking at
mammals the answer was human beings are
the most common which was very
interesting to me
uh i almost didn't believe it but i was
trying to you know eight billion or so
human beings
there's no other mammal that's got more
than eight billion
if you walk through downtown edinburgh
and scotland and you look up on this
hill and there's castle up on the hill
you know and you talk to people
and the story is oh yeah well that was
uh that was a british casual before it
was a scottish castle before it was pick
castle before as a roman castle before
it was you know
some other celtic castle before you know
then they found 13 prehistoric castles
buried one under the other under the
other
and you get to you get the conclusion
that a hundred thousand years ago
somebody showed up and grabbed the high
point the apex
of the city
and they built a stronghold there
and they flourished and their family
flourished and their tribe flourished
until someone came along and knocked him
off the hill
and it's been a a nonstop never ending
fight by the
the aggressive most powerful entity
family organization municipality tribe
whatever off the hill for that one hill
going back since time and memorial
and
you know
you scratch your head and
and you think it seems like it's like
just this
ending
but does not lead
if you just
all kinds of metrics that seems to
improve
the quality of our cannons and ships as
a result like it seems that war
just like your laser eyes focuses the
mind on the engineering tasks it is that
and and and
it does remind you
that the winner is always the most
powerful and
and we we throw that phrase out but no
one thinks about what that phrase means
like like who's the most powerful or the
you know or the most powerful side one
but they don't think about it and they
think about power
energy delivered in a period of time and
then you think
a guy with a spear is more powerful than
someone with their fist and someone with
a bow and arrow is more powerful than
the person with the spear and then you
realize that somebody with bronze is
more powerful than without and steel is
more powerful than bronze and if you
look at the romans
you know they persevered you know with
artillery and they could stand off from
800 meters and blast you to smithereens
right they
you know you study the history of the
balearic slingers right and you know you
think we invented bullets but they they
invented bullets to put in slings
thousands of years ago they could have
stood off 500 meters and put a hole in
your head
right and so there was never a time
when uh when
humanity wasn't vying
to come up with an asymmetric form of
projecting their own power via
technology
an absolute power is when a leader is
able to control a large amount
of uh humans they're
facing the same direction
working in the same direction to
leverage uh energy the most organized
society wins
yeah when the romans were
were
dominating everybody they were the most
organized civilization
in europe and
as long as they stayed organized
they dominated and at some point they
over expanded and got disorganized and
they collapsed
and uh i guess you could say that you
know the struggle of the human condition
it catalyzes the development of new
technologies one after the other it
penalizes
anybody that
rejects ocean power
right gets penalized you reject
artillery you get penalized you reject
atomic power you get penalized if you
reject digital power cyber power you get
penalized
and uh
and the the underlying control of the
property keeps shifting hands from
you know one institution or one
government to another based upon how
rationally they're able to channel that
energy
and how well organized or coordinated
they are well that's really interesting
thing about both the human mind and
governments
that they once they get a few good and
companies once they get a few good ideas
they seem to stick with them
they reject new ideas
it's almost uh whether that's emergent
or
however that evolved
it seems to have a really interesting
effect because when you're young
you fight for the new ideas you push
them through then a few of us
humans find success then we get
complacent
we take over the world using that new
idea and then
the the the new young person with the
better new idea
uh challenges you and you uh as opposed
to pivoting you stick with the old and
lose because of it and that's how
empires collapse and it's just both at
the individual level that happens when
two academics fighting about ideas or
something like that and at the uh
at the human civilization level
governments they hold on to the ideas of
old
it's fascinating
yeah an ever persistent
theme in the history of science is the
paradigm shift and the paradigms
shift when the old guard dies and a new
generation arrives
or the paradigm shifts when there's a
war
and everyone that disagrees with the
idea
of aviation finds bombs dropping on
their head or everyone that disagrees
with whatever your technology is has a
rude awakening and if they totally
disagree their society collapses and
they're replaced by
that new thing
a lot of the engineering you talked
about
had to do with ships and cannons
and leveraging water what about this
whole digital thing that's happening
been happening over the past
century
is that still engineering your mind
you're starting to operate in these bits
of information
i think there's two big ideas uh the
first wave
of ideas were digital information and
that was the internet way been running
since
1990 or so for 30 years and the second
wave is digital energy
so if i look at digital information
this idea that we want to digitally
transform a book
i'm going to de-materialize every book
in this room into bits and then i'm
going to deliver a copy of the entire
library to a billion people and i'm
going to do it
for
pretty much de minimis electricity
if i can dematerialize music
books education
entertainment
maps
right
that
that uh is an incredibly
like exothermic transaction it gives
it's a crystallization when we collapse
into a lower energy state as a
civilization we give off massive amounts
of energy
like if you look at what carnegie did
the richest man in the world created
libraries everywhere at the time and he
gave away his entire fortune and now we
can give a better library to every six
year old for nothing and so
what's the value of giving a million
books to a
eight billion people
right that's that's the explosion in
prosperity that comes from digital
transformation
and uh when we do it with maps
you know i i transform the map i put it
into a car you get in the car and the
car drives you where you want to go with
the map
right and how much better is that than a
rand mcnally atlas right here it's like
it's like a million times better
so
the first wave of digital transformation
was the dematerialization
of all of these informational things
which are non-conservative that is you
know i could take beethoven's fifth
symphony played for by the best
orchestra in germany and i could give it
to a billion people and they could play
it a thousand times each
at less than the cost of the one
performance right so so i deliver
culture and education and air addition
and
intelligence and insight to the entire
civilization
over digital rails
and the consequences of the human race
are
first order generally good
right the world is a better place it
drives growth and you create these
trillion dollar entities like apple and
amazon and facebook and google and
microsoft
right that is the first wave
the second wave do you mind i'm sorry to
interrupt but that first wave
um
it feels like
the impact that's positive
you said the first order impact is
generally positive it feels like it's
positive in a way that nothing else in
history has been positive
and then we may not actually
truly
uh be able to understand
the orders and magnitude of
increase in productivity in
just progress of human civilization
uh until we look back centuries from now
it just feels or maybe i'm like that
just like just looking at the impact of
wikipedia
right
the
giving access to basic wisdom or basic
knowledge and then perhaps wisdom to
billions of people if you can just
linger on that for a second
what's your sense of the impact of that
you know i
i would say if you're
a technologist
philosopher
the impact of a technology is so much
greater on the civilization and the
human condition than
a non-technology that is almost not
worth your trouble to bother trying to
fix things a conventional way so let's
take example um
i have a foundation the sailor academy
and the sailor academy gives away
uh
free education free college education to
anybody on earth that wants it
and we've had more than a million
students
and if you go when you take the physics
class
the lectures were by the same physics
lecture that taught me physics at mit
except when i was at mit
the cost of the first four weeks of mit
would have drained my family's life
collective life savings for the first
last hundred years yep like a hundred
years worth of my father my grandfather
my great-grandfather they saved every
penny they had after 100 years they
could have paid for one week or two
weeks of mit that's how fiendishly
expensive and inefficient it was so
yes i went on scholarship i was lucky to
have a scholarship
but
on the other hand i sat in the back of
the 801 lecture hall and i was like
right up in the rafters it's an awful
experience on these like uncomfortable
wooden benches and you can barely see
the blackboard and you got to be there
synchronously
and the stuff we upload you can start it
and stop it and watch it on your ipad or
watch it on your computer and rewind it
multiple times and sit in a comfortable
chair and you can do it from anywhere on
earth and it's absolutely free
so i think about this and i think
you want to improve the human condition
you need people with
post-graduate level education you need
phds and i know this sounds kind of
elitist but you want to cure cancer and
you know you want to go to the stars
fusion drive we need new propulsion
right we need we need extraordinary
breakthroughs
in every area of basic science you know
be it biology or propulsion or material
science or computer science you're not
doing that with an undergraduate degree
you're certainly not doing it with a
high school education but the cost of a
phd is like a million bucks
there's like 10 million phds in the
world if you go do the if you check it
out there's 8 billion people in the
world how many people could get a phd or
would want to maybe not 8 billion but a
billion 500 million let's just say 500
million to a billion how do you go from
10 million to a billion
highly educated people all of them
specializing
in
and i don't have to tell you how many
different fields of human endeavor there
are i mean your life is interviewing
these experts and
there's so many
right you know it's it's it's amazing so
how do i give a multi-million dollar
education to a billion people and
there's two choices
you can either endow a scholarship in
which case you pay 75 000 a year
okay
75 let's pay a million dollars and a
million dollars a person i can do it
that way
and you're never
even if you had a trillion dollars
if you had 10 trillion dollars to throw
at the problem and we've just thrown 10
trillion dollars at certain problems
yeah you don't solve the problem
right if i if i put 10 trillion dollars
on the table and i said educate
everybody give them all a phd you still
wouldn't solve the problem harvard
university can't educate
eighteen thousand people
simultaneously or eighty seven thousand
or eight hundred thousand or eight
million so you have to dematerialize the
professor and dematerialize the
experience so you put it all as
streaming on demand computer generated
education
and you create simulations where you
need to create simulations and you
upload it
it's like the human condition is being
held back by
000 well-meaning
um average algebra teachers
i love them i mean please don't take
offense if you're an algebra teacher but
instead of 500 000 algebra teachers
going through the same motion over and
over again
what you need is is like one or five or
ten really good algebra teachers and
they need to do it a billion times a day
or billion times a year for free
and if we do that
there's no reason why you can't give
infinite
education
certainly in
science technology engineering and math
right
infinite education to everybody
with no constraint
and i i think the same is true right
with just about every other thing you
if you want to
bring joy to the world you need digital
music if you want to bring you know
enlightenment to the world you need
digital education
if if you you know want to bring
anything of consequence in the world you
got to digitally transform it and then
you got to manufacture it something like
a hundred times more efficiently as a
start but a million times more
efficiently
is is probably
often you know that's that's hopeful
maybe you have a chance and
if you look at all of these uh space
endeavors and everything we're thinking
about getting to mars getting off the
planet getting to other worlds
number one thing you got to do is you
got to make a fundamental breakthrough
in an engine
people dreamed about flying for
thousands of years but until until the
internal combustion engine
you didn't have enough
you know enough energy enough enough
power in a light enough package
in order to solve the problem
and what and the human race has all
sorts of those
fundamental
engines
and materials and techniques
that we need to master and each one of
them is a lifetime of experimentation of
someone
capable of making a seminal contribution
to the body of human knowledge there are
certain problems like education that
could be solved through this pro process
of dematerialization and by the way
to give props to the 500k
algebra teachers
when i look at youtube for example
one possible approach is each one of
those 500 000 teachers probably had days
and moments of brilliance and if they
had ability to contribute to
in the natural selection process like
the market
of education
where the best ones rise up that's
that's a really interesting way which is
like the best
the best day of your life the best
lesson you've ever taught
could be
found
and sort of broadcast to billions of
people
so all of those kinds of ideas can be
made real in the digital world now
traveling across planets
you still can't solve that problem
uh with dematerialization what you could
solve potentially is
dematerializing the human brain where
you can transfer and transfer you like
you don't need to have astronauts on the
ship you can have a floppy disk carrying
a human brain
touching on those points you'd love for
the 500 000 algebra teachers to become
500 000 math specialists and maybe they
clump into 50 000 specialties as teams
and they all pursue 50 000 new problems
and they put their algebra teaching on
autopilot
that's the same that's the same as when
i give you 11 cents worth of electricity
and you don't have to
row uh you know row a boat eight hours a
day before you can eat right yes
it would be a lot better you know that
you would pay for your food in the first
eight seconds of your day and then you
could start thinking about other things
right
um
with regard to
technology you know
one thing that i learned studying
technology when you look at s-curves is
until you start the s-curve
you don't know whether you're a hundred
years from viability
a thousand years from viability or a few
months from viability
so
isn't that fun that's so fun
the the early part of the s curve is so
fun
because you don't know in 1900 you could
have got any number of learned academics
to give you 10 000 reasons why humans
will never fly yeah right and in 1903
the wright brothers flew and by 1969
we're walking on the moon so
the advance that we made in that field
was extraordinary but for the hundred
years and 200 years before they were
just back and forth and nobody was close
and um
and that's the the happy part the happy
part is we went from
flying 20 miles an hour or whatever to
flying 25 000 miles an hour
in
66 years
the unhappy part
is i studied aeronautical engineering at
mit in the 80s
and in the 80s we had
gulf stream aircraft we had boeing 737s
we had the space shuttle
and you fast forward 40 years
and we pretty much had the same exact
aircraft this you know that the
efficiency of the engines was
20 30 percent more yeah right with we
slammed into a brick wall around 69 to
75.
like in fact uh you know the global
express the gulf stream these are all
engineered in the 70s some in the 60s
that the actual
the fuselage uh silhouette of a gulf
stream of a g5 was the same shape as a
g4 is the same shape as a g3 is the same
shape as a g2 and that's because they
were afraid to change the shape for 40
years because they worked it out in a
wind tunnel i knew it worked
and when they finally decided to change
the shape it was like a 10 billion
dollar exercise with modern
supercomputers and computational
fluid dynamics why was it so hard what
was
what is what is that wall made of the
slammed into but the right question is
so why does a guy that went to mit that
got an aeronautical engineering degree
spent his career in software
like why is it that i never a day in my
life
with the exception of some air force
reserve work i never got paid to be an
aeronautical engineer and i worked in
software engineering my entire career
maybe software engineering is the new
aeronautical engineering in some way
maybe like maybe you hit fundamental
walls uncertain
until you have to return to it centuries
later
or no the national gallery of art was
endowed by a very rich man
andrew mellon and you know how he made
his money
aluminum
okay
and and so
yeah and you know what kind of airplanes
you can create without aluminum
i think
nothing right so that's a material so
it's a materials problem okay so
1900 we we made massive advances in
metallurgy right i mean that was that
was u.s steel that was iron to steel
aluminum
massive fortunes were created because
this was a massive technical advance and
then we also had the internal combustion
engine and you know the story of ford
and general motors and daimler chrysler
and the like is informed by that
so you have no jet engines no rocket
motors no internal combustion engines
you have no aviation
but even if you had those engines if you
were trying to build those things with
steel
no chance you had to have aluminum so
there's like
two
pretty basic technologies and once you
have those two technologies stuff
happens very fast
so
tell me the the
the last big advance in like jet engines
there hasn't been one
like there had the last big advance in
rocket engines how's it been one the big
advances in spaceship design from what i
can see are in the control systems the
the gyros and the ability to land
right in a stable fashion that's pretty
amazing landing a rocket also in the um
at least according to
the elon and so on the manufacturer of
the
more efficient and less expensive
manufacturer of rockets
so like it's a production whatever that
you call that discipline of
at scale manufacture at scale production
so factory work but it's not 10x
i mean maybe it's 10x over a period of a
few decades when we figure out how to
operate a
spaceship you know on the water in your
water bottle for a year
yeah right now then you've got a
breakthrough so the bottom line is
propulsion
propel propulsion technology uh
propellants and the materials technology
they were critical to getting on that
aviation s-curve and then we slammed
into a wall
in the 70s
and the boeing 747
the global express the gulf stream these
things were the space shuttle
they were all pretty much reflective of
that and then we kind of
then we stopped and at that point you
have to switch to a new s curve so
the next
equivalent to the internal combustion
engine was the cpu and the next aluminum
equipment was silicon so when we
actually started developing cpus
transistor gateway to cpus and if you
look at the
the power
right the bandwidth that we had on
computers and moore's law right
what if the efficiency of jet engines
had doubled
every three years
right in the last 40 years where we be
right now right
so
so i i think that if you're if you're a
business person if you're looking for
commercially viable
application of your mind
then you have to find that s-curve and
ideally
you you have to find it in the first
five six ten years
but people always miss this let's take
google glass
right google glass was a idea 2013
the year is 2022
and people were quite sure this was
going to be a big thing but it could
have been
at the at the beginning of the s curve
but fundamentally
we didn't really have an effective
mechanism i mean people getting vertigo
and they're yeah but you didn't know
that at the beginning of this
right i mean maybe some people had a
deep intuition about the fundamentals of
augmented reality but you don't know
that you don't have those uh you're
looking through the fog you don't know
so the point is we're year zero in 2013
and we're still year zero in 2022 on
that augmented reality and when somebody
puts out a set of glasses
that you can wear comfortably without
getting vertigo
right
without any disorientation that managed
to have the stability and the bandwidth
necessary to sync
with the real world you'll be in year
one
and and from that point you'll have a
70-year or some some interesting future
until you slam into a limit to growth
yeah
and then it'll slow down
and
this
this is the story of a lot of things
right i mean john d rockefeller got in
the oil business in the 1860s
and the oil business as we understood it
you know became fairly mature you know
by
the 1920s the 30s and then it actually
stayed that way until we got to fracking
and like which was like 70 years later
and then it burst forward
so the interesting story about moore's
law though is that you get this like
constant burst of s s curves on top of
eskers on top of esker it's like the
moment you start slowing down
or almost ahead of you slowing down you
come up with another innovation another
innovation so moore's law doesn't seem
to happen in every
technological advancement
it seems like you only get a couple of
s-curves and then you're done for a bit
so i wonder what the pressures there are
that resulted in such success over
several decades and still going
humility dictates that nobody knows when
the s curve kicks off and you could be
20 years earlier 100 years early
leonardo da vinci you know they were
michelangelo they were designing flying
machines
hundreds and hundreds of years ago so
humility says you're not quite sure when
it's when you really hit that commercial
viability and it also dictates you don't
know when it ends
like
when will the party stop when will
moore's law stop and we'll get to the
point where they're exponentially
diminishing returns on
silicon performance
and when you just like we got
exponentially diminishing returns on jet
engines
you know
and it just takes an exponential
increase in effort to make it 10 percent
better
but while you're in the middle of it
then you know you can do things so
the reason that the digital revolution
is so important is because the
underlying platforms the bandwidth of
and the performance of the components
and
i said the components are the
radio
protocols
mobile protocols the uh the batteries
the cpus
and the displays right
those those four components are pretty
critical they're all they're all
critical in the creation of an iphone i
wrote about it in the book the mobile
wave and they catalyzed this entire
mobile
revolution
because they have advanced and continued
to advance
they created a very fertile environment
for
all these digital transformations
and
the digital transformations themself
right they they call for creativity in
their own right like like i think the
interesting thing about
let's take uh digital maps right when
you when you conceptualize something as
a dematerialized map
right it becomes a map because
i can put it on a display like an ipad
or i can put it in a car like a tesla
but
if you really want to figure it out you
can't think like an engineer you need to
think like a fantasy writer like this is
where it's useful if you studied uh if
you read played dungeons and dragons and
you read lord of the rings and you
you study all the fantasy literature
because
because when i dematerialize the map
first i put 10 million pages of
satellite imagery into
the map right that's a simple physical
transform
but then i start to put telemetry into
the map and i keep track of the traffic
rates on the roads and i tell you
whether you'll be in a traffic jam if
you drive that way and i tell you which
way to drive
and then i start to get feedback on
where you're going and i tell you the
restaurant's closed and people don't
like it anyway
and then i put an ai on top of it and i
have it drive your car for you
and eventually
the implication of digital
transformation of maps is i get in a
self-driving car and i say take me
someplace cool where i can eat
right and and how did you get to that
last step right it wasn't simple
engineering there's a bit of fantasy in
there a bit of magic design art whatever
the heck you call it it's whatever yeah
fantasy injects
magic into the engineering process like
imagination
like precedes
great
revolutions in engineering it's like
like imagining a world like
uh of what you can do with the display
how will the interaction be that's where
google glass actually came in augmented
reality virtual reality people are
playing in the space of
sci-fi
imagination they called a moon shot they
tried it didn't work but to their credit
they stopped trying right it's like oh
and then there's new people they keep
dreaming dreamers are all [ __ ] all around
us i love those dreamers and most of
them fail and suffer because of it but
some of them when win nobel prizes or
become billionaires
but what i would say is
if half the civilization
dropped what they were doing tomorrow
and eagerly started working
on launching a rocket to alpha centauri
it might not be the best use of our
resources because
it's it's kind of like if half of athens
in the year 500 bc eagerly started
working on flying machines if you went
back and you said what advice would you
give them
don't you would say
you know it's not going to work till you
get to aluminum and you're not going to
get to aluminum till you work out the
steel and and certain other things and
you're not going to get to that until
you work out the calculus of variations
and some metallurgy and there's a dude
newton that won't come along for quite a
while and he's going to give you the
calculus to do it and until then it's
hopeless so you you might be better off
to work on the aqueduct or to focus upon
sales or something so if if i look at
this today i say
there's massive profound
environment civilization advances to be
made through digital transformation of
information and you can see them like
that this is
the story of today this is not the story
of today right it's 10 years old what
we've been seeing we're living through
different manifestations of that story
today too though like social media uh
that
the effects of that is very interesting
because ideas spread even you talk about
velocity of money the velocity of ideas
keeps increasing yeah so like wikipedia
is a passive store it's a store of
knowledge
twitter is like a
uh
it's like a
water hose or something it's like
spraying you with knowledge whether you
want it or not it's like social media is
just like this explosion of ideas and
then we pick them up and then we try to
understand ourselves because the drama
of it
also plays with our human psyche so
sometimes there's more
ability for misinformation for
propaganda to take hold so we get to
learn about ourselves we get to learn
about the technology they can decelerate
their propaganda for example all that
kind of stuff but like the reality is
we're living i feel like we're living
through a singularity in the digital
information space
and we're not we don't have a great
understanding of exactly how it's
transforming our lives
this is where money is useful as a as a
metaphor for significance because
if money is the is the
economic energy of the civilization
then something that's extraordinarily
lucrative that's going to generate a
monetary or a wealth increase is a way
to increase the net energy in the
civilization and ultimately
if we had 10 times as much of everything
we'd have a lot more
free resources to pursue all of our
advanced scientific and mathematical and
theoretical endeavors so let's take
twitter
right twitter's something that could be
10 times more valuable than it is right
twitter's twitter could be made 10 times
better
oh by the way i should say that people
should follow you on twitter your
twitter con is awesome thank you
it could be made ten times better yeah
yeah twitter can be made ten times
better uh if we take
if we take youtube or take education
we could generate a billion phds and and
the question is do you need any profound
uh breakthrough in materials or
technology to do that answers not really
right so if you wanna
you could make apple amazon facebook
google twitter all these things better
the
the united states government if they
took one percent
of the money they spend on the
department of education
and they simply poured it into digital
education and they gave
degrees to people that actually met
those requirements
they could provide 100x as much
education for 1 100th of the cost and
they could do it with no new technology
that's a
a marketing and political
challenge so i don't think every
objective
is equally practical
and i think the benefit of being an
engineer or or thinking about uh
practical achievements is
when the government pursues an
impractical objective or when anybody an
entrepreneur
not so bad with an entrepreneur because
they don't have that much money waste
when a government pursues an impractical
objective they squander trillions and
trillions of dollars and achieve nothing
whereas if they uh pursue a practical
objective or if the or if they simply
get out of the way
and do nothing
and they allow the free market to pursue
the practical objectives then i think
you can have profound
impact on the human civilization
and if i
if i look at
the world we're in today
i think that there
there are
multi-trillion
10 20 50 trillion dollars worth of
opportunities
in the digital information realm yet to
be obtained
um
[Music]
but there's hundreds of trillions of
dollars of opportunities in the digital
energy realm
that
not only are they not obtained the
majority of people
don't even know what digital energy is
most of them would reject the concept
they're not looking for it
they're not expecting to find it it's
inconceivable because it is a paradigm
shift but in fact it's completely
practical
right under our nose
it's staring at us and it could make the
entire civilization work dramatically
better in every every respect so you
mentioned
in the digital world digital information
is one digital energy is two
and the possible
impact on the world and the set of
opportunities available in the digital
energy space
is much greater so how do you think
about the general energy what is it
so i i'll start with tesla
he had a very famous quote he said if
you understand the universe think in
terms of energy
vibration and frequency
and it gets you thinking about what is
the universe and of course the universe
is just all energy
and then what is matter
matter is low frequency energy
and what are we you know we're vibrating
from you know ashes to ashes dust to
dust
i can turn a tree into light
i can turn light back into a tree if if
i consider the entire universe and it's
very important because we don't really
think this way let's take the new york
disco model
what it if i walk into a nightclub and
there's loud music blaring in new york
city
what's really going on there
right if if you blast out 15 14 billion
years ago the universe is formed okay
that's a low frequency thing the
universe
four and a half billion years ago the
sun maybe the earth or form
the continents are 400 million years old
the shift that new york city is on is
some hundreds of millions of years but
the hudson river is only 20 000 years
there's a building that's probably 50
years old there's a company operating
that disco or that club which is 5 to 10
years old
there's a person a customer walking in
there for an experience for a few hours
there's music
that's uh oscillating it's some
kilohertz
and then there's light right and you and
you have all forms of energy
all frequencies
right all layered all moving through
different medium
and the co and how you perceive the
world's a question of
at what frequency do you want to
perceive the world
and um
i i think that once you
start to think that way you
you're
catalyzed to think about what would
digital energy look like and and
why would i want it
and um
what is it so
why don't we just start right there what
is it
the most famous manifestation of digital
energy is bitcoin
bitcoin's a crypto asset it's a crypto
asset that has monetary value can we
just linger on that
bitcoin is uh is a
uh
so it's digital asset that has monetary
value
what is a digital asset what is monetary
why use those terms versus the words of
money and and currency is there
something interesting in that
disambiguation of different terms
i'd call it a crypto asset network
the goal is to create
a billion dollar block
of pure energy in cyberspace
one that i could that i could then move
with no friction at the speed of light
right it's it's the equivalent to
putting a million pounds in orbit
how do i actually
launch
something into orbit right how do i
launch something into cyberspace that
such that it moves friction free and the
solution
is a you know decentralized
proof-of-work network right satoshi's
solution was
i'm going to establish protocol running
on a distributed set of computers that
will maintain a constant supply of never
more than 21 million bitcoin
subdividable by a hundred million
satoshis each
transferable
via transferring private keys
now the innovation
is uh
to create that in a
ethical
durable
fashion right the the ethical innovation
is i want it to be property and not a
security
a bushel of corn
an acre of land a stack of lumber and a
bar of gold
and a bitcoin are all property and that
means they're all
commonly occurring elements in the world
you could call them commodities but
commodity is a little bit misleading and
i'll tell you why in a second
but they're all distinguished by the
fact that no one entity or person or
government controls them
if you have a barrel of oil
and you're in ukraine versus russia
versus saudi arabia versus the us
you have a barrel of oil
right and it doesn't matter what the
premier in in japan
or the mayor of miami beach thinks about
your bill they cannot wave their hand
and make it not a barrel of oil or a
cord of wood right
and so property is just a naturally
occurring element in the universe
right
why use the word ethical and sorry to i
may interrupt occasionally
why why ethical assigned to property
because if it's a security a security
would be an example of a share of a
stock
or a crypto token controlled by a small
team
and and in the event that something is a
security because
some small group or some identifiable
group can control its nature character
supply
then
it really only becomes ethical to
promote it or sell it pursuant to fair
disclosures
so i'll give you maybe practical example
i'm the mayor of chicago
i give a speech
my speech i say i think everybody in
chicago should own their own farm
and have chicken a chicken in the
backyard and their own horse and an
automobile
that's ethical
i give the same speech and i say i think
everybody in chicago should buy twitter
stock
sell their house or sell their cash and
buy twitter stock
well is that ethical
not really but at that point you've
entered into a conflict of interest
because what you're doing is you're
promoting um an asset
which is substantially controlled by a
small group of people the board of
directors or the ceo of the company so
if you know how would you feel the
president united states said i really
think americans should all
buy apple stock
you would you know especially if you
worked at google or but you worked
anywhere you'd be like why isn't he
saying buy mine
right a security is um
is a proprietary asset in some way shape
or form the and the whole nature of
securities law it starts from this
ancient
ancient idea thou shalt not lie cheat or
steal
okay
so
if
if uh i'm going to sell you securities
or i'm going to promote securities as a
public figure or as an influencer or
anybody else
right if
if i create my own yo-yo coin or mikey
coin and then there's a million of them
and i tell you that i think that it's a
really good thing and mikeycoin will go
up forever
right everybody buys mikeycoin and then
i give 10 million to you and don't tell
the public right i've cheated them
maybe if if i have mikeycoin and i think
there's only two million mikeycoin and i
swear to you there's only two million
and then i get married and i have three
kids and my third kid is in the hospital
and my kid's gonna die and i have this
ethical reason to print five hundred
thousand more mikey coin or else people
are gonna die and everybody tells me
it's fine
you know i've still abused you know the
investor right it's
it's a ethical challenge
if you look at um ethics laws
um everywhere in the world
they all boil down to having a clause
which says that if you're a public
figure you can't endorse
any a security you can't endorse
something that would cause you to have a
conflict of interest
so if you're a mayor a governor a
country a public figure an influencer
and you want to promote or promulgate or
support something using any public
influence or funds or resources you may
have
it needs to be property it can't be
security
so
it goes beyond that right i mean like
would the chinese want to support an
american company
right as soon as you look at what's in
the best interest of the human race the
civilization
you realize that
if you want an ethical path forward uh
it needs to be based on
common property
which is fair
and the way you get to a common property
is through an open permissionless
protocol
if it's not open right if it's
proprietary and i know what the code
says and you don't know what the code
says that's that makes it a security
if uh
if it's uh permissioned
if you're not allowed on my network or
if you can be censored or booted off my
network
that also makes it a security
um
so
so when i talk about uh property i mean
the challenge here is how do i create
something that's equivalent to a barrel
of oil
in cyberspace
and that means it has to be a a
non-sovereign bearer instrument open
permissionless not censorable
right
if i could do that
then i could deliver you ten thousand
dematerialized barrels of oil
and you would take
settlement of them
and you would know that you have
possession of that property irregardless
of the opinion of any politician or any
company or anybody else in the world
uh that that's uh a really critical
characteristic and and it actually is
it's probably one of the fundamental
things that makes bitcoin special
bitcoin isn't just a crypto asset
network it's easy to create a crypto
asset network it's very hard
uh to create an ethical
crypto asset network because
you ha you have to create one
without any government or corporate
corporation or investor exercising into
influence to make it successful so open
permissionless
non-sensorable
so basically no way
for you without
explicitly saying so outsourcing control
to somebody else so it's a kind of
you have full control
even with the barrel of oil
um what's the difference in between a
barrel of oil and a bitcoin
to you
what is the
because you kind of
mentioned that both are property is uh
you mentioned russia and china and so on
is is it the ability of the government
to confiscate
in the end governments can probably
confiscate no matter what the asset is
but you want to lessen the
um effort involved a barrel oil is a
bucket of physical property liquidity
bitcoin is a digital property but it's
easier to confiscate
a barrel of oil
it's easier to confiscate things in the
real world than things in cyberspace
much easier so that's not universally
true some things in the digital space
are actually easier to confiscate
because
um
just the nature of how things move
easily with information right so i think
in the bitcoin world what we would say
is that is the bitcoin is the most
difficult property
that the human race possesses or has yet
invented to confiscate and that's by
virtue of the fact that you could take
possession of it by your private key so
you know if you got your 12 seed phrases
in your head
then that would be the highest form of
property right because i literally have
to crack your head open and read your
mind
to take it it doesn't mean i couldn't
extract it from you under duress but
it means that it's harder than every
other thing you might own if you and in
fact it's exponentially harder if you
consider every other thing you might own
a car a house a share of stock
gold diamonds
property rights intellectual property
rights movie rights music right anything
imaginable they would all be easier by
orders and orders of magnitude to seize
so
so digital property and the form of a
you know
a set of private keys is by far the apex
property of the human race
in terms of ethics i want to make one
more point it's like
i might say to you lex
i think bitcoin is the is the best most
secure most durable crypto asset network
in the world is going to go up forever
and there's nothing better in the world
i might be right
i might be wrong
but the point is because it's property
it's ethical for me to say that
if i were to turn around and say you
know lex i think the same about
microstrategy stock mstr that's a
security okay if i'm wrong about that i
have civil liability or other liability
because
because i could go to a board meeting
tomorrow and i could actually propose we
issue a million more shares of
microstrategy stock
whereas
the thing that makes bitcoin ethical for
me to even promote is the knowledge that
i can't change it if if i knew
that i could make it 42 million instead
of 21 million and i had the button back
here yeah
right then then i have a different
degree of ethical responsibility now i
could tell you your life will be better
if you buy bitcoin and it might not you
might go buy bitcoin you might lose the
keys and be bankrupt and your life ends
and your life is not better because you
bought bitcoin right
but
it wouldn't be my ethical liability any
more than if i were to say
lex i think you ought to get a farm
i think you should be a farmer i think a
chicken in every pot you should get a
horse
i think you'd be better i mean these are
all uh they're all
opinions expressed about property
which may or may not be right that you
may or may not agree with
but in a legal sense
if we read the law if we understand
securities law
and i would say you know most people in
the crypto industry you know
they don't they didn't take companies
public and so they're not really focused
on the securities law they don't even
know the securities law
if you focus on the securities law that
would say you just can't legally
sell this stuff to the general public or
promote it without a full set of
continuing disclosures signed off on by
a regulator
so
so uh there's a fairly bright line there
with regard to securities but when you
get to the
when you get to the secondary issue it's
how do you actually build a world
based on digital property
if public figures
can't
can't embrace it or endorse it
you see so you're not going to build a
better world based upon
twitter stock if that's your idea of
property because twitter stock is a
security and twitter stock is never
going to be a non-sovereign bearer
instrument in russia right or in china
right it's not even legal in china right
so it's not a global permissionless open
thing it will never be trusted by the
rest of the world and
legally it's impractical but you know
would you really want to put a hundred
trillion dollars worth of economic value
on twitter stock if there's a board of
directors and a ceo that could just get
up and like take half of it tomorrow the
answer is no so
if you want to if you want to build a
better world
based on digital energy
you need to start with constructing a
digital property
and i'm using property here
open permissionless in a legal sense
okay but i would also go to the next
step and say
property is
low frequency money
so if you if i give you a million
dollars
and you want to hold it for a decade
you might go buy a house with it
right and
the house is low frequency money you
converted the
the million dollars of economic energy
into a structure called a house maybe
and after a decade you might convert it
back into energy you might sell the
house for currency
and it'll be more worth more or less
depending upon the monetary climate the
frequency means what here uh how quickly
it changes state how quickly does
something vibrate
so
if uh if i transfer
ten dollars from me to you
for a drink
and then you turn around you buy another
right we're vibrating on a frequency of
every few hours right the energy is
changing hands but it's not likely that
you sell and buy houses every few hours
right the frequency of um of a of a
transaction in real estate is every 10
years every five years it's a much lower
frequency transaction
and um
so
when you think about uh what's going on
here you have extremely low frequency
things
which we'll call property then you have
mid-frequency
things i'm going to call a money or
currency
and then you have high frequency
and that's energy
and that's why i use the illustration of
you got the building you got the light
and you got the sound and they're all
just
energy moving at different frequencies
now
bitcoin is magical
and it's it is truly the innovation it's
like a singularity because it represents
the first time in the history of human
race that we managed to create
a digital
property properly understood
it's it's easy to create something
digital
right every coupon and every skin on
fortnite and roblox and and apple tv
credits and all these things they're all
digital something but they're securities
right shares of stock are securities
whenever anybody
transfers when you transfer money on
paypal or apple pay you're transferring
in essence a security or an iou
and so transferring a bearer instrument
with final settlement in in the internet
domain or in cyberspace
that's a critical thing and and
anybody in the crypto world can do that
all the cryptos can do that
but what they can't do what 99 of them
fail to do is be property
they're securities well there's a line
there i'd like to explore a little
further for example
uh what about when you
um like coinbase or something like that
when there's an exchange
that you buy bitcoin is uh in
you start to move away
from this kind of
some of the
some of the aspects
that you said makes up a property
which is this um
non-sensorable
and permissionless and open
so in order to achieve the convenience
the effectiveness of the
of the transfer of energy you have to
leverage some of these um
places that remove the aspects of
property so i mean maybe you can comment
on that let me give you a good model for
that
if you think about the layer one of
bitcoin
the layer one is is the property
settlement layer and we're we're going
to do 350 000 transactions or less a day
100 million transactions a year is the
bandwidth on the layer one and
it would be an ideal layer of one to
move a billion dollars from point a to
point b with the massive security
the role of the layer one is is two
things
one thing is i want to move a large sum
of money
through space
with security i i can move
any amount of bitcoin in a matter of
minutes
for dollars
on layer one
that the second important
feature of the layer one is i need the
money to last forever
right i need the money indestructible
immortal so so the bigger trick is not
to move a billion dollars from here to
tokyo the big trick is to move a billion
dollars from here to the year 2140
and uh and that's
that's what we want to solve with layer
one and and the best real metaphor in
new york city would be the granite or
the schist
what you want is a city block
of a bedrock and how long has it been
there like
millions of years it's been there and
how fast you want it to move
you don't
in fact the single thing that's most
important is that it not deflect
if it deflects
a foot in a hundred years it's too much
if it deflects an inch and a hundred
years you might not want that
so the layer one of bitcoin is a
foundation upon which you put weight how
much weight can you put on it
you put a trillion 10 trillion 100
trillion
a quadrillion
how much weight is in on the bedrock in
in manhattan right think about hundred
story buildings so
the the real key there is the
foundational asset needs to be there at
all so the fact that you can create
a hundred trillion dollar layer one that
would stand for a hundred years that is
the revolutionary breakthrough first
time and the fact that it's ethical
right it's ethical and it's common
property global permissionless extremely
unlikely that would happen
people tried 50 times before and they
all failed they tried 15 000 times after
and they've all been they've all
generally failed 98 have failed and a
couple have like
been less successful but
for the most part
that's
an extraordinary thing now just really
quickly pause just to define some terms
if you people don't know
layer one is uh that michael's referring
to is
in general what people
know of as the bitcoin technology
originally defined which is the
blockchain there's a consensus mechanism
of proof of work
uh low number of transactions but you
can
[Music]
move a very large amount of
money the reason he's using the term
layer one is now that there's a lot of
ideas of layer two technologies built on
top of this bedrock
that allow you to move a much larger
number of transactions
um so sort of uh
higher frequency i don't know how what
terminology you want to use but
basically be able to use now something
that is based on bitcoin to then uh buy
stuff be a consumer to transfer money to
use it as currency
just to define some terms
yeah
so
the layer one is the foundation for the
entire cyber economy
and um
we don't want it to move fast what we
want what we want is is immortality
incorrupt immortal and corruptible
indestructible
right that that's what you want
integrity from the layer one now there's
layer two and layer three and layer two
i would define as an open permissionless
non-custodial
protocol
that uses uh the underlying layer one
token as its as its gas fee so what's
custodial mean and how does the
different markets like uh is lightning
network so lightning network would be an
example of a layer two non-custodial
so the lightning network
will sit on top of uh of layer one it'll
sit on top of bitcoin
and it solves the what you want to do is
solve the problem of
it's well and fine i don't want to move
a billion dollars every day what i want
to move is five dollars
a billion times a day
so if i want to move five dollars a
billion times a day i don't really need
to put the entire trillion
dollars of assets at risk every time i
move five dollars
all i really need to do is put a hundred
thousand dollars in a channel or a
million dollars in a channel and then i
do 10 million transactions where i have
a million dollars at risk
and of course it's it's kind of simple
if i if i put
if i lower my security requirement by a
factor of a million
i can probably move the stuff a million
times faster
and that's how lightning works it's
non-custodial because there's no there's
no corporation or custodian or
counterparty you're trusting
right there's a there's the risk of
moving through the channel
but um
lightning is an example of how i go from
350 000 transactions a day to 350
million transactions a day so on that
layer too you could move the bitcoin in
seconds for fractions of pennies
now
that's not the end-all be-all because
the truth is there are a lot of open
protocols lightning probably won't be
the only one there could you know
there's an open market competition of
other permissionless open source
protocols to do this work
um and in theory
any any other crypto network that was
deemed to be
property deemed to be non-security you
would all you could also think of as
potentially a layer two to bitcoin right
there's a debate about are there any and
what are they and and we could leave
that for a later time but why do you
think of them
as layer two as opposed to contending
for layer one
yeah actually if they're using their own
token
then they are a layer one if you create
an open protocol that uses the bitcoin
token as the as the fee
then it becomes a layer two okay right
bitcoin itself right incentivizes his
own transactions with its own token and
that's what makes it layer one
okay what's layer three then layer three
is a custodial layer
so if you wanna move bitcoin in
milliseconds for free
you move it through binance or coin base
or cash app
so this is a very straightforward thing
i mean it seems pretty obvious when you
think about it that they're gonna be
hundreds of thousands of layer threes
there may be dozens of layer twos there
might i mean lightning is a1 but it's
not the only one anybody can invent
something
right and and
we can have this debate uh about
custodial non-custodial um
don't you think there's amount of
monopolization possibilities at layer
three
so
um
you know coin you mentioned binance coin
coinbase what if they start to dominate
and basically everybody is using them
practically speaking and then it becomes
too costly to
memorize the uh the private key in your
brain
i mean or like a cold storage of layer
one technology the idealist
fear the layer threes because they think
and especially they did test
they would detest a bit
there's almost like a layer four by the
way if you want to a layer four would be
i've got bitcoin on an application but i
can't withdraw it
so i've got an application that's backed
by bitcoin but the bitcoin is sealed
it's it's a proprietary example and i'll
give you example of that that would be
like
grayscale
if i own a share of gbtc
and and so i own a security actually
you know you could own mstr
if you own a security or you own a
product that has bitcoin embedded in it
you get the benefits of bitcoin but you
don't have the ability to withdraw
the asset so you have a security market
at layer four am i understanding this
correctly
i don't know if i would say
i don't not all securities are layer
four but but anything that's a
proprietary product based upon with
bitcoin embedded in it where you can't
withdraw the bitcoin
is another application of bitcoin
so if if you think about different ways
you can use this
you can either stay completely on the
layer one and use the base chain for
your transactions
or you can
limit yourself to layer one and layer
two lightning and the purist would say
we stay there get your bitcoin off the
exchange
but you could also go to the layer three
when cash app uh supported bitcoin they
made it very easy to buy it and then
they gave you the withdrawal
when paypal or i think robin hood let
you buy it they wouldn't let you
withdraw it and it was a big community
uproar and people want
they want these layer threes to to make
it possible to withdraw the bitcoins you
could take it to your own private wallet
and get it off the exchange
i think the answer to the question of
well is corruption possible is
corruption is possible and all human
institutions and all governments
everywhere the difference between
digital property and physical property
is when you own a building in los
angeles
and the city
politics turn against you you can't move
the building
yeah and when you own a share of a
security
that's like a u.s traded security and
you wish to move to some other country
you can't take the security with you
either
and when you own a bunch of gold and you
try to get through the airport they
might
not let you take it so
uh
bitcoin is advantageous versus all those
because you actually do have the option
to withdraw your asset from the exchange
and if you you know if you had bitcoin
with fidelity and you had shares of
stock with fidelity and if you had uh
bonds and sovereign debt with fidelity
if you owned some
some
you know mutual funds and some other
random limited partnerships with
fidelity none of those things can be
removed from the custodian but the
bitcoin you can
take off uh the exchange you can remove
from the custodian so
so uh
it's still possible there's a deterrent
there's a deterrent that's an
anti-corrupting element
and the phrase is an armed society is a
polite society
right because you have the optionality
to withdraw all your assets from the
crypto exchange you can enforce fairness
and at the point where you disagree with
their policies
you can within an hour move your assets
to another counterparty or take personal
custody of those assets
and you don't have that option with most
other forms of property maybe you don't
have as much optionality
with any other form of property on earth
and so what what makes digital property
distinct
is the fact that it has the most
optionality for custody
now coming back to this digital energy
issue the real key point is
the energy moves in milliseconds for
free on layer threes
it moves in seconds or less than seconds
on layer twos it moves in minutes on the
layer one
and
it i don't think it makes any sense to
even think about trying to solve all
three problems on the layer one because
it's impossible to achieve the security
and the incorruptibility and immortality
if you try to build that much speed and
that functionality and performance
in fact
if you come back to the new york model
you really wanted a block of granite a
building and a company
that's what makes the economy
right if you say if i said to you you're
going to build a building but you can
only have one company in it for the life
of the building it would be very fragile
like very brittle what company a hundred
years ago is still relevant today
you want all three layers because they
all oscillated different frequencies
and
and you know there's a tendency to think
well it's it's got to be this l1 or that
l1 not really and sometimes people think
well i don't really want any l3 but
companies
it's not an even war companies are
better
than
crypto asset networks at certain things
if you want complexity you want to
implement complexity or you want to
implement compliance
or customer service right
companies do these things well
right
we know
you couldn't decentralize apple or
netflix or even youtube the performance
wouldn't be there
and the subtlety wouldn't be there and
you can't really legally decentralize
certain forms of banking and insurance
because they become illegal in the
political jurisdiction they're in so
unless you're a crypto anarchist and you
believe in no companies and no nation
states
right
which it's just not very practical not
anytime soon once you allow that nation
states will continue and companies have
a role
then the layered architecture follows
and
the free market determines who wins
for example
there are layer threes that uh that let
you acquire bitcoin and withdraw bitcoin
there are there are other applications
to let you acquire but not withdraw it
and and they're
they don't get the same market share but
they might give you some other advantage
there are there are certain layer threes
like jack dorsey's cache app where they
just incorporated lightning
an implementation of it so
uh
it's a cache app so that makes it more
that makes it advantageous versus uh
an application that doesn't incorporate
lightning
if you think about
the big picture the big picture is eight
billion people with mobile phones served
by a hundred million companies doing
billions of transactions an hour
and
and the companies are settling with each
other on the base layer in blocks of 80
million at a time
and then the companies are trading with
the consumers
right
in
proprietary layers like layer 3 and then
on occasion people are shuffling assets
across custodians with lightning layer
two because you don't want to pay five
dollars to move fifty dollars you wanna
pay
a twentieth of a penny to move fifty
dollars
and so
all of these things create efficiency in
the economy
and lex if you want to consider how much
efficiency
if if you gave me a billion dollars in
20 years i couldn't find a way to trade
with another company or a counterparty
in nigeria
like
no no amount of money give me 10 billion
dollars i couldn't do it
because you get shut down at the banking
level you can't link up a bank in
nigeria with the bank in the us
you get shut down at this credit card
level because they don't have the credit
card so they won't clear
you get shut down at the at the
compliance fcpa
level because
because uh if you know you wouldn't be
able to implement a system that
interfaced with somebody else's system
if it's not in the right political
jurisdiction
on the other hand three entrepreneurs in
nigeria on the weekend could create a
website that would trade in this
lightning economy using open protocols
without asking anybody's permission
so you're talking about something that's
like a million times cheaper
less friction and faster
to do it
if you want it if you want to get
money to move
what do you think that looks like so
that now there's a war going on in
ukraine
there's other wars yemen going on
throughout the world
in in this
most
difficult of states that a nation can be
in which is at war
uh civil war or war with other nations
what's the role of bitcoin
in this context
i mean bitcoin's a universal trust
protocol right a universal energy
protocol if you will
english is one
okay um what i see is a bunch of
fragmentation of applications for
example you know the russian payment app
is not going to work in ukraine right
the ukraine payment app is not going to
work in russia the you know u.s payment
apps won't work either of those places
as far as i know
so you know and and in argentina their
payment app may not work in certain
parts of africa so what you have is
is uh different local economies where
people spin up their own applications
compliant
with their own local laws or
you know in in war zones not compliant
but just
just spinning up you know how do you
build something that's not compliant
what is the revolutionary act here when
you don't agree
with the government or what you want to
free yourself from the constitution so
here's the thing
the when a nation is really at war
is it's the the especially if it's an
authoritarian regime it's going to try
to control the popular like lock
everything down yeah the spread of
information how do you break through
that do you do the thing that you
mentioned which is you have to build
another app essentially that allows you
the flow of money outside the
legal constraints placed on you by the
government so basically break the law
um
metaphorically speaking if you want to
break out the constraints of your
culture you learn to speak english
for example it's not illegal to speak
english or even if it is right it
doesn't matter but but english works
everywhere in the world if you can speak
it and then you can tap into a global
commerce and intelligence network so
bitcoin is a language so you learn to
speak bitcoin or you learn to speak
lightning and then you tap into that
network in
you know whatever manner you can but the
problem is it's still very difficult to
move bitcoin around
in russia and ukraine now doing war
and there was a
sense to me that
the cryptocurrency in general could be
the savior
for helping people there's millions of
refugees they're moving all all around
it's very it's very difficult to
move money around in that space to help
people
i think we're very early
like like we're very embryonic here if
you look at the who's we sorry and we as
a human civilization are we
operating in the cryptocurrency space i
think the entire crypto economy is very
embryonic and and the human race's
adoption of it is embryonic we're like
one two percent down that adoption curve
if you take lightning for example the
you know the first real commercial
applications of lightning are just in
the last 12 months
yeah so we're like year one we might be
approaching year two of commercial
lightning adoption and if you look at
lightning adoption
lightning is not built into
coinbase it's not built into binance
it's not built into ftx it's it you know
cache app just implemented the first
implementation but not all the features
are built into it there's
a few dozen a dozen lightning wallets
circulating out there
so i i think that you know we're
probably going to be 36 months of
software development
at the point that um
every android phone and every iphone has
um
has a bitcoin wallet or a crypto wallet
in it of sorts
that's a big deal if if apple embraced
lightning that's a big deal
so the adoption is the thing like in a
war zone adoption
um the people who struggle the most in
war are people who are weren't doing
that great before the war started they
don't have the technological
sophistication the the hackers and all
those kinds of people will find a way
uh it's just regular people who are just
struggling to make day-by-day living and
so if the adoption
permeates the entire culture
then you can start to move money right
around um
in the digital space
what if from a
psycho if you can psychoanalyze jack
dorsey for a second
so he's one of the early adopters or
he's one of the people pushing the early
adoption in this layer three
so inside cash app what do you make of
the man
of this decision
as a business owner
as somebody playing in the space like
what um
why did he do it and
what does that mean for others
at the scale that might be doing the
same so incorporating lightning
networking incorporating bitcoin into
their products
i think he's been pretty clear about
this
he feels that bitcoin is an instrument
of economic empowerment for billions of
people that are unbanked and have no
property rights
in the world
if you want to give
an incorruptible bank
to
8 billion people on the planet
that's the same as asking the question
how do you give a full education
through phd to 8 billion people on the
planet
and the answer is
a digital version
of the 20th century thing running on a
mobile phone
and bitcoin is a bank in cyberspace it's
run by uncorruptable software and it's
for everybody on earth
so i think when jack looks at it he's
very sensitive to the plight of
everybody in africa
if you look at africans right like
you're going to give them banks you're
not going to put a bank branch on every
corner that's an obscene waste of energy
you're not going to run copper wires
across the continent that's an obscene
waste of energy
you're not gonna
give them gold and you know so so how
are you going to
provide people with a decent life
that the metaphor i think is is relevant
here the biological metaphor lex is type
1 diabetic
if you're a type 1 diabetic you can't
form fat and if you can't form fat
then you can't store excess energy so
that means that i mean fat is the
ultimate organic battery and if you've
got 30 pounds of it you can go 60 days
without eating
but if you can't
generate insulin you can't form fat
cells if you can't form fat cells and
store energy then you can eat yourself
to death i mean you will eat and you
will die you're starved to death
so the lack of property rights
is like being a type one diabetic
and so if you look at most people
everywhere in the world
they don't have property rights
they don't have effective bank and they
don't and their currency is broken
like what are what are the two things
that in theory would serve as the
equivalent of a
uh of uh
an organic battery or an economic
battery to civilization would be
i have a currency which holds its value
and i can store it in a bank so a risk
a risk-free
currency derivative
i yeah i pay you your money you take
your life savings you put it in the bank
you save up for your retirement you live
happily ever after that's the american
dream
right that's the idyllic situation
the real situation is
there are no banks you can't get a bank
account so i give you your pay in
currency and then i double the supply
and i give it to my cousin
or i give it to whatever clause i want
or i use it to buy weapons and then you
find a loaf of bread cost triple next
month is what it cost and your life
savings is worthless
and so in that environment
everybody's ripped back to stone age
barter
and the problem with that even stone age
barter is
you're going to carry your life savings
on your back and what happens when the
guy with a machine gun points it at your
head and just takes your life saving so
so i think from jack's point of view
he thinks that life
is this is maybe too strong but i these
are my words life is hopeless for a lot
of people
and bitcoin is hope
right because because it gives everyone
um
an engineered
monetary asset that's a bearer
instrument
and it gives them a bank on their mobile
phone
and they they don't have to trust their
government or another counterparty
with their life force
so
i there's a secondary thing i think he's
interested in which is
the first thing is the human rights
issue and the second thing would be
the friction to to trade cross borders
is so great right
yeah like uh
i i you know you're like ai
so i'll give you a beautiful notion
maybe one day there'll be an
artificially intelligent creature in
cyberspace
that is self-sufficient and rich
like that we would have sovereignty
can a robot
own money or property
how about kind of tesla car can i
actually put enough muff money in a car
for it to drive itself and maintain
itself forever or can i create an
artificially intelligent creature in
cyberspace that is endowed
such that it would live a thousand years
and continue to do its job
right
you know we have a word for that in the
real world it's institution harvard
cambridge stanford right there are
institutions with endowments that go on
in perpetuity
but what if i wanted to perpetuate
a software program
and um
with uh with something like digital
property with bitcoin and lightning
you could do it
and on the other hand
with uh banks and credit cards
you couldn't
right
you couldn't ever so so you can create
things that are beautiful
and lasting
uh and uh what's the difference in speed
well
so
i can either trade with everybody in the
world
at the speed of light friction free in
24 hours writing a python script or
i can spend 100 billion dollars to trade
with a few million people in the world
after it takes them six months
of application the impedance
is like a 10 million to one difference
right and the metaphors are literally
like launching something in orbit versus
almost orbit or vacuum sealing something
does it last forever and does it orbit
forever or does it go up and come down
and burn up
right and i think jack is interested in
you know
putting freedom in orbit all right
putting freedom putting freedom in orbit
and he said it many times he said this
is the the internet needs a native
currency yeah right and and
no political construct or security
can be a native currency you need a
property and you need a property that
can be moved a million times a second
can you oscillate it at 10 kilohertz or
100
kilohertz and the answer is
only
if it's a pure digital construct
permissionless and open
and so i think he that he's enthusiastic
as the technologist and he's
enthusiastic as the humanitarian
and what he's doing
is uh to support both those areas he's
supporting the bitcoin and the lightning
protocol by building them into his
products but he's also building the
applications
which you need at the cash app level in
order to commercialize
and deliver the functionality and
compliance necessary and
they're related
and
i should also say he's just a
fascinating person i
for a random reason
that i couldn't even explain if i tried
i met him a few days ago and gave him a
great big hug in the middle of nowhere
there was no explanation he just
appeared that's a fascinating human his
relationship with art with the world
with human suffering with technology is
fascinating
um i don't i don't know what his path
looks like but it's interesting that
people like that exist
and in part i'm saddened that he no
longer is involved with twitter
directly as a ceo
because i was hoping something inside
twitter would also
integrate some of these ideas
of what you're calling digital energy
um to see how social networks something
i'm really interested in and passionate
about could be transformed
let me ask you just for educational
purposes
what's the uh
can you please explain to me what web 3
and the beef between jack and marc
andreessen is exactly did you see what
happened sorry to have you analyze
twitter like it's shakespeare but
can you please explain to me why why
there was any any drama over this topic
first of all web 3
is a term that's used uh to refer to
you know the part of the economy that's
that's token finance so if i'm launching
an application and my ideas is to create
a token along with the application
and issue the token to the community so
as to finance the application and build
support for it
i think that uh
i think that that's the most common
interpretation of web three there are
other interpretations too and so i'm
just gonna refer to that one and i think
the beef
in a nutshell not articulated but i'll
articulate it is
whether or not
you should focus all your energy
creating applications on top of an
ethical digital property like bitcoin
or whether you should attempt to create
a competitor
to it
which
generally
would be deemed as a security by the
bitcoin community so i'm going to put on
my bitcoin hat here yeah right all the
tokens that have been if it's driven by
a venture capitalist was a security if
there's a ceo and a cto it's a security
all these projects they're companies
foundations or companies right if you
call them a project or a foundation it
doesn't make it
not a security they're all in essence
um collections of individuals that are
issuing equity in the form of a token
and if if there's a pre-mine an ipo
an ico a foundation or any kind of
any kind of uh protocol where there is a
a group of engineers that have influence
over it
then
to a securities lawyer or or you know to
most bitcoiners and definitely to
anybody that's steeped in securities law
you're looking to say well that passes
the howie test
it's uh it looks like a security it
should be sold to the public pursuant to
you know disclosures and regulations
and you're just ducking the ipo process
right and and so
now we get back to the ethical issue
well the the ethical issue is
if you're trading it as a commodity and
representing it as a commodity while
truthfully it's a security you know then
it's a violation of ethics rules and
it's probably illegal well you're you
keep leaning on this let me push back on
that part maybe you can educate me but
you keep leaning on this line of
security's law as if
it
with all due respect to lawyers
as as if
that line somehow defines what it what
isn't isn't ethical i think there's a
lot of uh correlation as you've
discussed but and i'd like to leave the
line aside i
uh if the law calls something as a
security it doesn't mean in my eyes that
it is unethical i mean there could be
some technicalities and
lawyers and people play games with this
kind of stuff all the time but i take
your bigger point that if there's a ceo
there's a project lead that's
fundamentally well that that's you is
fundamentally different than
the the structure of bitcoin it's not
that creating securities is unethical i
i created security i took a company
public
right
that's not the unethical part it's
completely ethical to create securities
you know block is a security all
companies are securities
the unethical part is to represent it as
property when it's a security and and uh
to promote it or trade it as such
this whole promotion
that's also a technical thing because
you're
i
like what what counts as a not as
promotion is a legal thing and you get
in trouble for all these things but that
that's the the game that lawyers play
there's an ethical thing here which is
like what's right to promote and not you
know uh
to me propaganda is unethical
but it's usually not illegal
[Laughter]
you're still talk back 20 years
right
all the boiler room pump and dump
schemes were all about someone pitching
a penny stock you know selling swampland
in florida
and uh
if you roll the clock back forward 20
years and i create my own
company and i represent it as the same
thing and i don't make the disclosures
right you're you're just one step
removed from the boiler room scheme and
that's what's distasteful about it
there are ways to sell securities to the
public but there are
but there are expectations
maybe
we could forget about whether the
security laws are ethical or not right i
will leave that alone we'll just start
with the biblical definition of ethics
yes don't lie cheat or steal
so if i'm going to sell something to you
i need to fully disclose what i'm
selling to you
right and and that
that's a matter of great debate right
now and um
so i think that that's part of the
debate but the other part of the debate
is
whether or not we need more than one
token
like uh
we need at least one right we need at
least one digital property one is
because zero means there is no digital
economy yes and by the way you know
the conventional view of maximalist is
they think there's only one and
everything else isn't
that's not the point i'm going to make i
i would say we know there is that as
there is at least one digital property
and that is bitcoin
if you can create a truly decentralized
non-cost
you know bearer instrument
that is not under the control of any
organization
that is fairly distributed
then you might create another or
multiple and there may be others out
there
but
i think that uh the frustration of a lot
of people in the bitcoin community and i
share this with jack is
we could create a hundred trillion
dollars of value in the real world
simply by building applications on top
of bitcoin
as a foundation
and so continually trying to reinvent
the wheel
and uh and create uh competitive things
is a massive
waste of time and it's diversion of
human
uh
human creativity it's like
we we have an ethical good thing
and now we're going to try to create a
third or a fourth one
why
well let's talk about it so um first of
all i'm with you but let me ask you this
interesting question because we talked
about properties and securities let's
talk about conflict of interest
so you said you could advertise public
you have a popular twitter account
it's
it's hilarious and insightful
uh you do promote bitcoin
in a sense i don't know if you would say
that
but do you think there's a conflict of
interest in anyone who owns bitcoin
promoting bitcoin is it the same as you
promoting the farming
i would say no
there's an interest
i think that i think that um you can
promote
a property
or an idea
to the extent that you don't control it
i think that the point at which you
start to have
a conflict of interest is when you're
promoting a proprietary product or
proprietary security a security in
general's proprietary asset so for
example if you look at my twitter
you will find that i make lots of
statements about bitcoin you won't ever
see me making a statement that say
microstrategy stock will go off forever
right i'm not promoting a security mstr
because at the end of the day mstr is a
security it is proprietary i have
proprietary interest in it i have a
disproportionate amount of control and
influence on the direction
the control is the problem because you
have interest in both
you can very if bitcoin is as successful
as we're talking about you are very
possibly can become the richest human on
earth
given how much you own in bitcoin right
the wealthiest not the richest i don't
know what those words mean
i would benefit economically economic
you would benefit economically that's
true so the
the reason that's not conflict of
interest is because uh
the word property
that bitcoin is an idea and
it's bitcoin is open
i don't control it in essence the the
the ethical line here
is could i print myself 10 million more
bitcoin or not
right
why can't anyone right it's not just you
it's it can can anyone
because can you promote somebody else's
yes i guess you can
like if you can you can promote uh
apple
you could have a twitter account where
you promote oil or you promote camping
or you promote family values or promote
you know a carnivore diet or promote the
iron man right that those are not going
to get wealthier if you promote camping
because you can't own a steak and i mean
you own a lot of bitcoin what is that
what is that what the game don't you own
at the stake in the idea
yeah i would i would grant you that
but the lack of control
is the fundamental ethical line that you
just you don't have
all you are is you're a fan of the idea
you believe in the idea and the power of
the idea
yeah i think you can't take that idea
away from others
let's come back to let me give you some
maybe easier examples if you were the
head of the marine corps
right
and uh
and someone came to you and said i
created marine coin
and uh and the twist on marine coin is
is i want you to tell every marine that
they'll get an extra marine coin you
know
when they when they get their next
stripe
and then i'm gonna give you you know i'm
gonna let you buy marine coin now and
then after you buy marine coin i want
you to like uh promote it
to them
right
at some point
if if you start to have a
disproportional influence on it or if
you're in a conversation with people
with disproportionate influence becomes
conflict of interest and it would make
you profoundly uncomfortable i think
yeah if the head of the marine corps
started promoting anything that looked
like a security
now if the head of the marine corps
started promoting canoeing
you might think he's kind of wacky like
maybe
like that's kind of a waste of time a
distraction so but but
but to the extent that
canoeing is not a security not a problem
unless you you know
ultimately the the issue of
decentralization is really a criticism
not having a head one so is is it
something
can bitcoin
be replicated
so the all the things that you're saying
that make it a property can that be
replicated have any other possible to
create other
crypto properties does it does the
having a head
like of a project
a thing that limits its ability to be a
property if you if you try to replicate
a project
is that the fundamental flaw i look i i
think the real fundamental issue is you
just never want it to change
like like uh
if you really want something
decentralized
you want a genetic template that
substantially is not going to change for
a thousand years so i think satoshi said
it at one point he said the nature of
the software is such that by version .1
its genetic code was set
if if there was any development team
that's continually changing it you know
on a routine basis it becomes harder and
harder
to maintain its decentralization because
now now there's the issue of who's
influencing
the changes yeah so what you really want
is
is a very very simple
idea right the simplest idea i'm just
going to keep track of who owns 21
million parts of energy
and when someone proposes big functional
upgrades
you almost don't you don't really want
that development to go on the base layer
you want that development to go on the
layer threes because
now cache app has a proprietary set of
functionality and it's a
security and if you're going to promote
the use of this thing you're not going
to you're not going to promote
the
layer 3 security because that's a an
edge to a given entity and you're
trusting the counterparty you're gonna
promote the layer one or at most
the layer two
okay so one of the fascinating things
about bitcoin
and sorry to romanticize certain notions
but satoshi nakamoto that the founder is
anonymous
maybe you can speak to whether that's
useful
but also i just like the psychology of
that to imagine that there's a human
being that was able to create something
special and walk away
so first are you satoshi nakamoto
i'm certain i'm not
[Laughter]
um
no i actually i you know i think the
providence is really important and if i
were to look at the highlighted points i
think
having a founder that was anonymous or
sit anonymous is important i think the
founder disappearing is also important i
think that the fact that the satoshi
coins never moved is also important
i think the the lack of an initial coin
offering is also important i think the
lack of a corporate sponsor is important
i think the fact that it traded for 15
months with no commercial value
was also important
you know i i think that um
the simplicity of the protocol
and is very important i think that the
the outcome of the block size wars is
very important and all of those things
add up to
common property they're they're all
indicia indicators of a digital property
as opposed to security
if there was a satoshi sitting around
sitting on top of
50 billion dollars worth of bitcoin it
would i don't think it would um
[ __ ]
bitcoin as property but i think it would
undermine
its digital property and if i wanted to
undermine a crypto asset network i would
do the opposite of all those things
i would launch one myself i would sell
25 or 50 percent of the general public i
would keep some of the initial i would
pre-mine some stuff or early mine it you
know and i would keep an influence on it
those are all
the opposite of what you would do in
order to create common property
and so i see the entire story is satoshi
giving a gift
of digital property
to the human race
and disappearing
do you think it was one person do you
have ideas of who it could be i
don't care to speculate
but do you think it was one person
like it was one person
maybe in conjunction with a bunch of
others i mean it might have been a group
of people that were working together but
certainly the there's a satoshi i mean
it's just so fascinating to me that one
person could be so brave
and thoughtful or do you think a lot of
his accent like the block size wars the
decision to make a block a certain size
all the things you mentioned led up to
the characteristics that make bitcoin
property
do you think that's an accident
or it was deeply thought through
like how does this is almost like a
history of science questions people
tried it for they tried 40 of them right
i mean i i think there's a there's a
history of attempting to create
something like this and it was tried
many many times and and they failed for
different reasons and i think that
it's like prometheus tried to start a
fire 47 times and maybe the 48th time
it's sparked
and and that's how i see this this is
the first one that's sparked
and uh and it sets a road map for us and
i and i think
if you're looking for any one word that
it's fair the whole point of the network
is it's a fair launch of fair
distribution
like
yeah
i have bitcoin but i bought it
in fact you know at this point we've
paid four billion dollars of you real
cash to buy it
if if i was sitting on the same position
and i had it for free
then there's always this question of
did i pay you know or i bought it for a
nickel a coin or a penny a coin the
question is was it fair and and that's a
very hard question to answer
right did you acquire the bitcoin that
you own fairly
and if you roll the clock back you know
you could have bought it for a nickel or
a dime but that was when it was a
million times more likely to fail
right when the risk was greater the cost
was lower and then over time the risk
became lower and the cost became greater
and the real critical thing was to allow
the marketplace absent any powerful
interested actor
right it's almost if satoshi had held a
million coins and then stayed engaged
for 10 more years tweaking things in the
background there'd still be that
question
but what we've got is really a beautiful
thing we've got a
we've got a chain reaction in cyberspace
or an ideology spreading virally in the
world
that um
that has seasoned in a fair
ethical fashion sometimes it's a very
violent brutal fashion with all the
volatility
right and there's been a lot of you know
a lot of sound and fury along the way
how do you psychoanalyze how do you deal
from a financial from a human
perspective with the volatility you
mentioned you could have gotten it for a
nickel and the risk was great
where's the risk today what's your sense
you know we're 13 years end to this
entire
activity i think the risk has never been
lower i i if you look at all the risks
right the risk the risks in the early
years
are
is the engineering protocol proper like
one megabyte block size 10 minute clock
frequency cryptography cryptographies
first will it be hacked or will it crash
730 000 blocks and it hasn't crashed
will it be hacked hasn't been hacked but
you know it's a lindy thing right you
wait 13 years to see if it'll be hacked
but on the other hand
with a billion dollars it's not as
interesting a target as it is with a
hundred billion and when it gets to be
worth a trillion
then it's a bigger target so
so the risk has been bleeding off over
time as the network monetized
i think the second question is will it
be banned
you couldn't know it could it literally
could have been banned at any time many
times early on in fact in 2013 i tweeted
on that subject i thought it would be
banned i i made a very fame infamous
famous tweet i thought it was it was
gonna be banned
in 2014 the irs um designated it as
property and gave it property tax
treatment okay so
they they could have given it a tax
treatment where you had to pay tax on on
the unrealized capital gains
every year and it probably would have
crushed it to death
right you know so
so it could have been in any
in any number of places banned by a
government but in fact it was
legitimized as property
and then the questions would it be
hacked or would it be copied well it'd
be something better than that and it was
copied 15 000 times and you know the
story of all those and
and they either diverge to be something
totally different and not comparable or
someone trying to copy
a non-sovereign bearer instrument store
of value found that the their networks
crashed to be one percent of what
bitcoin is so
now we're sitting
at a point where all those risks are out
of the out of the way
i would say that year one of
institutional adoption
is uh it started august
2020 that's when microstrategy bought
250 million dollars worth of bitcoin and
we put that on the wire we were the
first publicly traded company to
actually buy
uh
bitcoin i don't think you could have
found a five million dollar purchase
from a public company before we did that
so that was kind of like a gun going off
and then in the next 12 months
tesla bought bitcoin square bought
bitcoin and i'd say now we're in year
two of institutional adoption and uh
about 24 should be 24 publicly traded
bitcoin miners by the end of this
quarter
so you're looking at 36 publicly traded
companies
and you've got
50
at least in a range of 50 billion
dollars on the balance of bitcoin on the
balance sheet of publicly traded
companies
and hundreds of billions of dollars of
market cap
of bitcoin exposed companies
so i i would say the asset
decade one was entrepreneurial
experimental
decade two is a rotation from
entrepreneurs institutions and is
becoming institutionalized so maybe
decade one you go from zero to a
trillion and a decade two you go from
one trillion to a hundred trillion what
about governments uh government adoption
institutional adoption is our
governments important in this maybe
making it
some governments
incorporating it into as a currency into
their banks
uh all that kind of stuff is that
important and if if it is when when will
it happen
it's not essential for the success of
the asset class but i think it's it's
inevitable in various degrees over time
but the most likely thing to happen next
is um
large uh acquisitions by institutional
investors
of bitcoin as a digital gold where
they're just swapping out gold for for
digital gold and thinking of it like
that
and the government entities most likely
to be involved with that would be
sovereign wealth funds
if you look at all the sovereign wealth
funds that are holding a big tech stock
uh equities the swiss the norwegians the
middle easterners
if you can hold big tech then holding
digital gold would be
you know not not far removed from that
that's a non-controversial
adoption
i think there are there are
opportunities for governments that are
much more profound right if a government
started to adopt
bitcoin as a treasury reserve asset
that's much bigger than just a
an asset investment that's 100 x bigger
and you could imagine that's like a
trillion dollar opportunity like any
government that wanted to adopt it as a
treasury reserve asset would probably
generate trillions of dollars a trillion
or more of value and then you know the
thing that people think about is well
will oil ever be priced in bitcoin
or any other export commodity
i think there's like 1.8 trillion
dollars or more of export commodities
in the world and right now they're all
priced in dollars i i think that this is
a colorful thing but it's not really
that relevant like you could sell all
that stuff in dollars that the relevant
decision that any institution makes
whether they're a non-profit a
university a corporation or a government
is what's your treasury reserve asset
and if your treasury reserve asset is
the peso and if the peso's
losing 20 or 30 of its value a year
then
you know your your balance sheet is
collapsing
within five years
and if the treasury reserve asset is uh
is dollars and
currency derivatives and u.s treasuries
then you're getting your
seven right now it's probably 15 percent
or more
uh monetary inflation we're running
double the historic average you could
argue triple somewhere between double
and triple depending upon
what your metric is
so you know do i think it'll happen i
think that they're conservative but they
have to be shocked and i think there is
a shock
the the late russian
sanctions are a big shock that when the
west sees 300 billion dollars worth of
russian gold and currency derivatives i
think it
you know you got the famous quote by
putin that you know
we have to rethink our our treasury
strategies and that pushes everybody
toward a commodity strategy what
commodities do i want to hold
i think that's got a lot of people
thinking i think it's got the chinese
thinking everybody wants to be the
reserve currency right so if i buy 50
billion dollars worth of dollars every
year then
i buy 500 billion
over a decade and i probably
pay
250 billion dollars of inflation cost on
the backs of my
citizens in a decade so
so inflation could be one of the sources
of shock
and you wonder if there is a switch to
bitcoin whether it would be a bang or a
whimper
like what is the nature of the shock of
the transition i think that uh
the year 2022 is pretty catalytic
for digital assets in general and for
for bitcoin in particular the canadian
trucker crisis
i think educated hundreds of millions of
people and and
made them start
questioning their property rights and
their banks
i think the
ukraine war
was a second shock but i think that the
russian sanctions was a third shock
yeah i think all three of the and i i
think hyperinflation in the rest of the
world is a fourth shock and then
persistent inflation the us is a fifth
shock
so i think it's a perfect storm
and if you put all these events together
what do they signify they signify the
rational conclusion for any person
thinking about this is
i'm not sure if i can trust my property
i don't know if i have property rights i
don't know if i can trust the bank
and if i'm politically at odds with
with uh the leader of my own country i'm
going to lose my property and
if i'm politically at odds with the
owner of another country
i'm still going to lose my property
and when push comes to shove the banks
will freeze my assets and seize them
and i think that
that that is playing out
in front of everybody in the world
such that
your logical
response would be
i'm going to convert my
weak currency to a strong currency
like i'll convert my peso and lira to
the dollar i'm going to convert my weak
property to strong property
i'm going to sell my building
downtown moscow
and i'd rather own
a building in new york city i'd rather
i'd rather own in a powerful nation than
a
than be stuck with a building in nigeria
or a building in argentina or whatever
so i'm going to sell my weak properties
by strong properties i'm going to
convert my physical assets to digital
assets
i'd rather own a digital building than
on a physical building
because if i had a billion dollar
building in moscow who can i rent that
to
but if i have a billion dollar digital
building i can rent it to anybody in any
city in the world
anybody with money and the maintenance
cost is
almost nothing and i can hold it for a
hundred years okay so it's
indestructible building and then finally
i want to move from
having my assets in a bank with a
counterparty to self-custody assets
right so and and this is not
it's not just ukraine but this is like
the story in turkey lebanon syria
afghanistan iraq
south america
you don't really want to be sitting with
10 million dollars
in a bank in istanbul the bank's gonna
freeze your money convert it to lira
devalue the lira and then feed it back
to you over 17 years right so
self-custody assets would be layer one
bitcoin
self-custody assets it's like
if i if i got my own hardware wallet and
i've either got
uh
[Music]
your your highest form of self-custody
would be bitcoin on your own hardware
wallet or bitcoin in your own
self-custody and the other the other
thing people think about is how do i get
crypto dollars like tether
like some stable coin yeah like i'd
rather if you had a choice would you
rather have your money in a bank in a
war zone in dollars or have your money
in a stable coin on your mobile phone
in dollars
right i mean you take the latter risk
rather than the former war zone
definitely yeah
and you can see that happening like
we've gone from 5 billion in stable
coins to 200 billion yeah in the last 24
months yeah so i do think there's
massive demand
for uh crypto dollars in the form of a
us dollar asset and there's
and everybody in the world would say
yeah i want that
well
unless you're just an extreme patriot
but most people would say i want that
and then a lesser group of people would
say i think i want to be able to carry
my property in the palm of my hand
so i have self-custody of it
so a bitcoin price has gone through
quite a roller coaster
what do you think is the high point it's
going to hit
i mean they don't go up forever right i
mean i i think the bitcoin is is going
to
it's going to climb in a serpentine
fashion it's going to advance and come
back and it's going to keep
it's going to keep climbing
i think that the volatility attracts all
the capital into the marketplace and so
the volatility makes it the most
interesting thing in the financial
universe it also generates massive yield
and massive returns for traders
and that attracts capital like we're
talking about the difference between
five percent return and 500 return
so
the fast money is attracted by the
volatility
the volatility's been decreasing year by
year by year i think that um that it's
stabilizing
i don't think we'll see as much
volatility in the future as we have in
the past
i think that um
[Music]
if we look at bitcoin and model it as uh
digital gold you know the market cap
goes to between 10 and 20 trillion
but
gold is remember gold is is defective
property gold is dead money
you have a billion dollars of gold that
says in a vault for a decade it's very
hard to mortgage the gold it's also very
hard to rent the gold you can't loan the
gold no one's going to create a business
with your gold
so gold that doesn't generate much of a
yield so for that reason most people
wouldn't store a billion dollars for a
decade in gold they would buy a billion
dollars of commercial real estate
property
and the reason why is because i can rent
it and generate a yield on it that's in
excess of the maintenance cost so if you
consider digital property
that's a hundred to two hundred trillion
dollar
uh addressable market so i would think
it you know it goes from ten trillion to
a hundred trillion as people start to
think of it as digital property what
does that mean in terms of price
uh per per coin at 500 000
right that's a 10 trillion dollar asset
at 5 million that's a 100 trillion
dollar asset so i think it crosses a
million it can go even higher
yeah i think it keeps going up forever i
mean there's no reason we couldn't go to
10 million a coin right because
digital property isn't the highest form
right gold was that low frequency money
property is a mid-frequency money but
when i start to
when i start to um program it
faster it starts to look like digital
energy
and and
then it doesn't just replace property
then you're starting to replace bonds
it's 100 trillion in bonds there's
50 to 100 trillion in other currency
derivatives
and then and then and these are all
conventional use cases right i think
that
there's 350
trillion to 500 trillion dollars worth
of currency currency derivatives in the
world
and that and when i say that i mean
things that are valued based upon fiat
cash flows any commercial real estate
any bond any sovereign debt any any
currency itself any derivatives to those
things
they're all
derivatives and they're all defective
and they're all defective because of
this persistent to 14 percent
lapse inflate which we call inflation or
monetary expansion can we switch uh
subjects to talk about the energy side
of it like the
innovative piece yeah let's just start
with this idea that i've got a a hotel
with a billion dollars with a thousand
rooms
when it becomes a dematerialized hotel
i love that word so much by the way do
you materialize
we're crossing the fountain blow here
imagine the fountain blow is
dematerialized yeah
the problem with the physical hotel is i
got to hire real people moving subject
to the speed of sound and physics laws
and newton's laws and i can rent it to
people in miami beach
but it was a digital hotel i could rent
the room to people in paris london and
new york every night
and i can run it with robots
and as soon as i do that i can rent it
by the room hour and i can run it by the
room minute and so i start to chop my
hotel up into
a hundred thousand room hours that i
sell to the highest bidder anywhere in
the world
and you can see all of a sudden the
yield
the rent and the income of the property
is dramatically increased
i can also see the maintenance cost of
the property falls
i get on moore's law
and i'm operating in cyberspace so i got
rid of newton's laws i got rid of all
the friction and all the all those
problems i i tapped into the benefits of
cyberspace
i created a global property
i started monetizing at different
frequencies and of course now i can
mortgage it to anybody in the world
right i mean you're not going to be able
to get a mortgage on a turkish building
from someone you know in south africa
you have to have to find someone that's
local to the
culture you're in
so
when you start to move from analog
property to digital property it's not
just a little bit better it's a lot
better and what i just described lex is
like the defy
vision right it's it's the beauty of d5
flash loans money moving at high
velocity
at some point
if
if the hotel is dematerialized
then what's the difference between
renting a hotel room and loaning a block
of stock
right i'm just finding the highest best
use of the thing
it feels like the magic really emerges
though when
uh you build a lot a market of layer two
and layer three technologies on top of
that so like
um
maybe you can correct me if i'm wrong
but for all these hotels and all these
kinds of ideas it's always
touching humans at some point
and the
um
you know consumers or humans business
owners and so on so you have to create
interface you have to create
services that make all that super
efficient super fun to use pleasant
effective all those kinds of things so
you have to build a whole economy on top
of that yeah i happen to think that
won't be done
by the crypto industry at all i think
that'll be done by centralized
applications
i think it'll be you know the citadels
of the world the high-speed traders of
the world the new yorkers
i think i think it'll be
binance ftx and coin base as a as a
layer 3 exchange that will give you the
yield and will give you the loan
and the the best terms
because ultimately you have to jump
these compliance hoops it's a it comes
like block fi can give you yield but
they have to do it in compliant way with
the united states jurisdiction
so ultimately those applications to use
that digital property and either
either
generate a loan give you a loan on it or
give you yield on it are going to come
from companies but the difference
the fundamental difference is
it could be companies anywhere in the
world so if a company in singapore
comes up with a better offering
right then the capital is going to start
to flow to singapore i can't send 10
city blocks of la to singapore to rent
during a festival but i can send 10
blocks of bitcoin to singapore
so you've got a truly global market
that's functioning and this asset and
it's a second order asset for example
maybe you're an american citizen and you
own 10 bitcoin and someone in singapore
will generate 27 yield in the bitcoin
but legally you can't send the money to
them or the bitcoin to them it doesn't
matter because the fact that that exists
means that someone in hong kong will
borrow the 10 bitcoin
from somebody in new york and then they
will put on the trade in singapore and
that will create a demand for bitcoin
which will drive up the price of bitcoin
which will result in an effective
tax-free yield for the person in the u.s
that's not even in the jurisdiction
so there's nothing that's going on in
singapore to drive up the price of your
land in l.a
but there is something going on
everywhere in the world to drive up the
price of property in cyberspace if
there's only one digital manhattan and
so
there's
there's a dynamic there which is
profound because it's global
but now let's go to the next extreme i'm
still giving you a fairly conventional
idea
which is let's just loan the money fast
on a global network and let's just rent
the hotel room fast in cyberspace
but now let's move to
maybe a more
innovative idea the first generation of
internet you know brought a lot of
productivity but there's also just a lot
of flaws in it
for example twitter is full of garbage
instagram dms are full of garbage your
twitter dms are full of garbage
youtube is full of scams
every 15 minutes there's a michael
sayler bitcoin giveaway spun up on
youtube yep
my office 365 inbox is full of garbage
millions of spam messages i'm running
four different
email filters
my company spends million dollars a year
to fight denial of service attacks and
all sorts of other
security things there are denial of
service attacks everywhere against
everybody in cyberspace all the time
it's extreme and we're all beset with
hostility right you you've been a victim
of it in twitter i'm you know you go on
twitter and and people post stuff they
would never say to your face and then if
you look you find out that the account
was created like three days ago
and it's not even a real person
so
you know we're beset with phishing
attacks and scams and spam bots and
garbage and why
and the answer is because the first
generation of internet was digital
information and there's no energy
there's no conservation of energy in
cyberspace
the thing that makes the universe work
is conservation of energy like if i went
to a hotel room
i'd have to post a credit card and then
if i smashed the place up
there'd be economic consequences
maybe criminal consequences
there might be reputational consequences
you know a lamp might fall on me
but in the worst case i can only smash
up one hotel room
now imagine i could actually write a
python script to send myself to every
hotel room in the world every minute
not post a credit card and smash them
all up
anonymously
right
the thing that makes the universe work
is friction
speed of sound speed of light
and the fact that
that it's ultimately it's conservative
you're either energy or your matter but
once you've used the energy it's gone
and you can't do infinite everything
that's missing
in cyberspace right now and if you look
at the
look at all of the moral hazards and all
of the product defects that we have in
all of these products
most of them 99 of them could be cured
if we introduced
conservation of energy into cyberspace
and that's what you can do with
high-speed digital property high-speed
bitcoin and and by high-speed i mean not
20 transactions a day i mean 20 000
transactions a day
so
how do you do that well um
i let everybody on twitter post a
thousand or ten thousand satoshis via a
lightning wallet a lightning badge
give me an orange check
if you put up 20 bucks once in your life
you could give 300 million people an
orange check
right now
you don't have a blue check lex you're a
famous person i don't know why you don't
have a blue check have you have you ever
applied for a blue check no there are
360 000 people on twitter with a blue
check there are 300 million people on
twitter
so the conventional way to verify uh
accounts
is elitist
archaic yeah how does it how does it
work how do you get blue check i mean
you go to apply and wait six months and
you have to
post you know like three articles in the
public mainstream media this illustrates
you're a person of interest
interesting generally they would grant
them to ceos of public companies or the
whole idea is to verify that you know
that you are
who you are who you say you are right
but the question is why isn't everybody
verified right and there's there's a
couple of threads on that one is some
people don't want to be doxxed they want
to be anonymous
but uh but there are even anonymous
people that should be verified right um
because otherwise uh you're you're
subjecting their entire following to
phishing attacks and scams and and
hostility
uh but the other
the other what's the orange verification
so the the this idea can you actually
elaborate a little bit more if you put
up 20 bucks yeah i think everybody on
twitter ought to be able to get an
orange check if they could come up with
like ten dollars and what is the power
of that orange
check what what does that verify exactly
you basically post a security deposit
for your safe passage through cyberspace
so the way it would work is if you if
you've got ten dollars once in your life
yeah you can basically show that you're
credit worthy
and that's your pledge to me
that you're going to act responsibly
so you put the 10 of the 20 into the
lightning wallet you get an orange check
then twitter just gives you a setting
where i can say the only people that
could dm me are orange checks the only
people that can post on my tweets or
orange checks
so instead of locking out the public and
just letting your followers
you know comment you lock out all the
unverified and that means people that
don't want to post 10 security deposit
can't comment
once you've done those two things
then uh you're in position to monetize
malice
right monetize motion or malice for that
matter but let's just say for the sake
of argument you post something and 9 700
bots
spin up you know and pitch their
whatever scam
right now you sit and you go report
report report report report report and
if you spend an hour
you get through half of them you waste
an hour of your life
they just spent up another 97 gazillion
because they've got a python script
spending it up so it's hopeless
but on the other hand if you report them
and they really are a bot it's
twitter's got a method to actually
delete the account they know that
they're bots
the problem is not they don't know how
to delete the account the problem is
there are no consequences when they
delete the account
so
if there are consequences
twitter could give they could just seize
the ten dollars or seize the twenty
dollars because it's a bot it's it's a
malicious criminal act or whatever it is
a violation of platform rules
you end up seizing ten thousand dollars
give half the money to the reporter and
half the money to the twitter platform
and it's a really powerful idea but that
that's tying it that's adding friction
akin to the kind of friction you have
in the physical world you're tying you
have consequences you have real
consequences
conservation of energy conservation of
energy there's no friction there's no
nothing on this earth
right i mean you can't walk across the
room without friction
right so that friction is not bad
right uh
unnecessary friction
is bad
so in this particular case you're
introducing conservation of energy and
in essence you're introducing the
concept of consequence or truth
into cyberspace
and that means if you do want to spin up
10 million fakes fake less freedmen's
rights
it's going to cost you 100 million
dollars to spend up 10 million fake
lexus the thing is you could do that
with the dollar but your case you're
saying that
it's
more
tied to physical reality when you do
that with bitcoin
yeah well let's follow up on that idea a
bit more
if you did do it with the dollar
then the question is how do six billion
people deposit the dollars
right because what you're doing is yeah
could you do it with a credit card like
how do you send dollars well you have to
dox yourself
like
it's not easy so you're talking about
inputting a credit card transaction
doxing yourself and now you've just
eliminated the two billion people that
don't have credit cards or don't have
banks you've also got a problem with
everybody that wants to remain anonymous
but you've also got this other problem
which is
credit you know credit cards are
expensive transactions low frequency
slow settlement
so
do you really want to pay two and a half
percent every time you actually show a
20 deposit and maybe you could do a
kludgy version of this for a subset of
people
it's like it's 10 as good if you did it
with
conventional payment rails but
what you can't do
is uh the next idea which is
i want the orange badge
to be used to give me safe passage
through cyberspace tripping across every
platform
so when i
how do i solve the denial of service
attacks against a website i publish a
website
you hit it with a million requests
okay now how do i deal with that well i
can lock you out and i can make it a
xero trust website and then you have to
be coming at me through a trusted
firewall with a trusted credential but
that's
that's a pretty draconian thing
or
i could put it behind a lightning wall
a lightning wall would be you know i
just challenge you lex uh you wanna um
browse my website you have to show me
your hundred thousand satoshi's do you
have a hundred thousand satoshi's
click
okay now you click away a hundred times
or a thousand times and after a thousand
times you know i'm like well now lex
you're getting offensive over to take a
satoshi from you or 10 satoshi's a micro
transaction you want to hit me a million
times i'm taking all your satoshis and
locking you out
what you want to do is you want to go
through 200 websites a day
and what you want every time you cross
a domain
you need to be able to in a split second
prove that you've got some asset and now
when you cross back when you exit domain
you want to fetch your asset back
so how do i in a friction free fashion
browse through dozens or hundreds of
websites
post a security deposit for state safe
passage and then get it back
you couldn't afford to pay a credit card
fee each time
it's when you think about two and a half
percent as a transaction fee
it means you trade the money
40 times
and it's gone
yeah it's gone yeah yeah so you can't do
this kind of hopping around through the
internet with this kind of uh
verification that grounds you to a
physical reality it's it's it's a really
really interesting idea why haven't
hasn't that been done
i i think you need uh two things you
need an idea like a digital asset like
bitcoin that's a bearer instrument for
final settlement and then you need a
high-speed transaction network like
lightning where the transaction cost
might be a 20th of a penny
or or less
and if you roll the clock back 24 months
i don't think you had
uh the lightning network in a stable
point it's really just the past 12
months it's an idea you could think
about this year
and i think you need to you need to
be aware of bitcoin as something other
than like a scary speculative asset
so i really think we're just the
beginning the embryonic stage
i have to ask michael saylor you said
before there's no second best to
bitcoin what would be the second best
traditionally there's ethereum with
smart contracts cardano with proof of
stake polka dot with uh
interoperability between blockchains
doshcoin has
the incredible power of the meme
uh
privacy with monero i just can keep
going there's the there's of course
after the
uh
block size wars
uh the different
offshoots of bitcoin i think if you if
you decompose or segment the crypto
market you've got crypto property
bitcoin is the king of that you know and
other bitcoin forks that want to be an
you know a bearer instrument store of
value it would be a property a bitcoin
cash or a litecoin something like that
then you've got crypto
currencies
i don't think i don't think bitcoin's a
currency because uh a currency i define
in nation states since a currency is an
a digital asset that you can transfer as
a you know in a transaction without
incurring a taxable obligation
so that means has to be a stable dollar
or a stable euro or a stable yen a
stable coin so i think you've got crypto
currencies tether circle most famous
then you've got crypto platforms you
know and ethereum is the most famous of
the crypto platforms the platform upon
which you know with smart contract
functionality etc
and then i think you've got just crypto
securities it's just like my favorite
whatever meme coin and i love it because
i love it and it's attached to my game
or my company or my persona or my
whatever
i think if you if you you know pushed me
and said well what's the second best i
would say the world wants two things it
wants crypto property as a savings
account and it wants cryptocurrency as a
checking account and that means that the
that the most popular thing really is
going to be a stable coin dollar
right and it's there's a maybe a fight
right now might be tether right but
a stable dollar because i feel like the
market
opportunity it's not clear that there'll
be one that will win the class of stable
dollars is probably a one to ten
trillion dollar market easily
i think that in the crypto platform
space ethereum will compete with solana
and binance smart chain and and the like
are there certain characteristics of any
of them that kind of stand out to you or
do you
don't you think the competition is based
on a set of features
also so the set of features that a the
cryptocurrency provides but also the
community that it provides does you
think the community matters and sort of
the adoption the dynamic of the adoption
both across the developers and the
internet i'm looking at them i mean the
first question is
is uh what's the regulatory risk how
likely is it to be deemed to property
versus security and the second is
is what's the competitive risk and the
third is what's the speed and the
performance and uh and the you know all
those things
you know lead to the question of what's
the security risk how likely is it to
crash and burn and and how stable or
unstable is it
and then there's the mar you know the
marketing risk i mean there are
different teams behind each of these
things and and communities behind them
i i think that um
the the big cloud looming over the
crypto industry
is regulatory treatment of
cryptocurrencies and regulatory
treatment of crypto securities and
crypto platforms and i think that won't
be determined until the end of the first
biden administration for example um
there are people that would like only
u.s u.s fdic
insured banks to issue cryptocurrencies
they want jp morgan to issue a crypto
dollar backed one-to-one
but then in the us right now we have
circle and we have other companies that
are licensed
entities that are backed by cash and
cash equivalents but they're not fdic
insured banks
there's also a debate in congress about
whether state chartered banks should be
able to issue these things and then we
have
tether and and others that are outside
of the u.s jurisdiction
they're probably not backed by cash and
cash equivalents they're backed by stuff
and we don't know what stuff
and then finally you have
you know ust and dye which are
algorithmic stable coins
right that are even uh more innovative
further outside the compliance framework
so if you ask who's going to win
the question is really
i don't know will the market decide or
will the regulators decide
if the regulators get out of the way and
the market fought out well then it's an
interesting discussion yeah and then i
think that all bets are off if if the
regulators get more heavy-handed with
this and i think you could have the same
discussion with crypto properties like
like the d5 exchanges and the crypto
exchanges the sec would like to regulate
the crypto exchanges they'd like to
regulate the d5 exchanges that means
they may regulate the crypto platforms
and and at what rate and in what fashion
and so i think that
i could give you an opinion if if it was
limited to competition and the current
regulatory regime
but
i think that the regulations are are so
fast moving and it's so uncertain
that it's
it it
you can't make a decision
without considering
uh the potential actions of the
regulators i hope the regulators get out
of the way
can you steal me on the case that
dogecoin is uh i guess the second best
cryptocurrency or if you don't consider
bitcoin a cryptocurrency but instead of
crypto property i would classify it as
crypto property because the us dollar is
a currency so unless your crypto asset
is pegged algorithmically or stably to
the value the dollar is not a currency
it's a property or it's an asset
so then can you still man the case that
doshcoin is the best cryptocurrency then
because bitcoin is not even in that list
the debate is going to be whether it's
property or security and there's a
debate whether it's decentralized enough
so let's assume it was decentralized yep
well it's it's increasing at not quite
five what five percent a year inflation
rate but it's it's not five percent
exponentially it's like a plus five
million
5 something captain is less
i forget the exact number but it's an
inflationary property it's got a lower
inflation rate
than the us dollar
and it's got a much lower inflation rate
than than uh many other fiat currencies
so i think you could say that but don't
you see the power of meme the power of
ideas the power of
uh fun or whatever mechanism is used to
uh
cap captivate a community i do but lara
meme stocks it doesn't absolve you of
your ethical and securities liabilities
if you're you know if you're promoting
it so like like i i don't have a problem
with like people buying a stock
it's just uh
the way i divide the world is right
there's investment there's saving
and there's speculation and there's
trading
so bitcoin
is an asset for saving if you want to
save money for a hundred years you don't
really want to take on execution risk
or the like so you're just buying
something to hold forever for for you to
actually endorse something as a property
like if you said to me mike what should
i
buy for the next hundred years i say
well some amount of real estate some
amount of scarce collectibles some
amount of bitcoin right you can run your
company
right but but running your company is an
investment so the savings are properties
if you said what should i invest in i'd
say well here's a list of good companies
private companies you can start your own
company that's an investment
right um
if you said what should i trade
well i'm trading as like a proprietary
thing like i'm i don't i don't have any
special
insight into that if you're a good
trader you know you are if you said to
me what should you speculate in
we talk about meme stocks
and meme coins
and and it's kind of sits up there it
sits right in the same space with what
horse should you bet on and what sports
team should you gamble on and should you
bet on black six times in a row and
double down each time
that's i mean it's fun but
at the end of the day
it's uh it's a speculation
right you can't build a civilization on
speculation on it it's not an
institutional asset and in fact
where i leave it right is bitcoin is
clearly digital progress which makes it
an institutional grade investable asset
for a public company a public figure a
public investor or anybody that's risk
adverse
i think that
the other the top 100 other cryptos are
like venture capital investments and if
you're a vc and if you're a qualified
technical investor and you have a pool
of capital and you can take that kind of
risk
then you can parse through that and form
opinions it's just
orders of magnitude more risky because
of competition because of ambition and
because of regulation
and if you take the meme coins it's like
you know when some rapper comes out with
a meme coin it's like
maybe it'll peak when i hear about it
right it's like
but i mean ship was created as a coin
such that it had so many zeros after the
decimal point that when you looked at it
on the exchanges it always showed zero
zero zero zero
and it wasn't until like six months
after it got popular that they started
expanding the display so you could see
whether the price had changed that's
speculation
uh you you've been
maybe you can correct me but you've been
critical of elon musk in the past
in the crypto space
where do you stand on elon's effect on
bitcoin and cryptocurrency in general
these days
i believe that bitcoin is a massive
breakthrough for the human race that
will cure half the problems in the world
and generate hundreds of trillions of
dollars of economic value to the
civilization
and i believe that um
it's an early stage
where many people don't understand it
and they're afraid of it and there's fud
and there's uncertainty there's doubt
and there's fear
and there's a very noisy crypto world
and there's 15 000 other cryptos that
are are seeking relevance
and i think most of the fud
uh is actually fueled by the other
crypto entrepreneurs so the
environmental fund and the other types
of of uncertainty that surround bitcoin
generally
they're not coming from legitimate
environmentalists they don't come from
legitimate uh
critics they actually are guerrilla
marketing campaigns
that are being financed and fueled by
other crypto
entrepreneurs because they have an
interest in doing so
so
if i look at the constructive path
forward
first i think it'd be very constructive
for corporations to embrace bitcoin
and and build applications on top of it
you don't you don't need to fix it
there's nothing wrong with it right like
when you put it on a layer two and a
layer three it moves a billion times a
second at the speed of light so every
beautiful cool defy application
every crypto application everything you
could imagine you might want to do you
can do
with a legitimate company
and a legitimate website or mobile
application sitting on top of bitcoin or
lightning
if you want to
so i think that um
to the extent that people do that that's
going to be better for the world
if you consider what holds people back i
think it's just misperceptions
about what bitcoin is so i'm a big fan
of just uh educating people if
if you're not if you're not going to
commercialize it then just educate
people on what it is so for example
bitcoin's the most efficient
use of energy in the world by far
right most people don't they don't
necessarily perceive that or realize
that but if you were to take any metric
energy intensity
you put like two billion dollars worth
of electricity in the network every year
and it's worth 850 billion dollars there
is no industry in the real world
right that that is that energy efficient
not only that energy efficient it's also
the most sustainable industry we just
we do surveys 58
of bitcoin mining energy is sustainable
so there's a very uh good story in fact
every other industry planes trains
automobiles construction food medicine
everything else
it's less clean
less efficient
so
so the basic debate would like to i
wouldn't say there is a debate i would
just say that to the extent that the
bitcoin community had any issue with
elon it was just you know the just this
environmental
you know
uncertainty that he fueled in a couple
of his tweets
right
uh which i think just is very
distracting
well that was one of them but i think
it's like the bitcoin maximalist but
generally the crypto community what you
call the the crypto entrepreneurs
are
you know it's also
they're using it for
i mean
for investment for speculation
and therefore get very passionate about
people's kind of uh
celebrities including you like famous
people right
um saying positive stuff about any one
particular
crypto
thing a thing you can buy in coinbase
and so um they might be unhappy with
elon musk that he's promoting bitcoin
and then not
and promoting dogecoin then not
and this kind of
um
there's so much emotion tied up in the
communication on this topic
and that's i think that's where a lot of
the
look i don't have
i don't have a criticism of elon musk
he's free to do whatever he wishes to do
it's his life in fact elon musk is the
you know the second largest supporter of
bitcoin in the world so i think that the
bitcoin community tends to eat its own
quite a bit yeah it tends to be very
uh very self-critical and instead of
saying
well elon is more supportive of bitcoin
than the other 10 000 people in the
world you know with serious amounts of
money they like they focus upon
you know yeah this is strange
eating your own is just um so i mean i
think he he's free to do what he wants
to do like and i i i think he's done a
lot of good for bitcoin in in putting it
on the balance sheet of tesla and
holding it and i think that sent a very
powerful message
do you have advice for young people so
you've had a heck of a life
uh you've done quite a lot of things
start before mit but starting with mit
is there advice here for young people in
high school and college
how to
um
have a career they can be proud of how
to have a life they can be proud of
i was asked by somebody
for quick advice
for
his young children he had he had twins
when they enter adulthood he said give
me give me your advice for them in a
letter
i'm going to give it to them when they
turn
21 or something
so
then he had i thought i was at a party
and then he handed me this sheet of
paper and i thought oh he wants me to
write it down right now so i i sat down
i started writing and i figured what
would you want to tell someone at age
21 you're already done so i wrote it
down and i tweeted it and it's sitting
on twitter but i tell you what i said i
said
my advice if you're entering adulthood
focus your energy
guard your
time train your mind
train your body
think for yourself
curate your friends
curate your environment
keep your promises
stay cheerful and constructive
and upgrade the world
like that was the 10. upgrade the world
that's an interesting choice of words
upgrade the world
upgrade the world
it's like an engineering energy it's a
very yeah it's a very engineering
themed
uh keep your promises too that's an
interesting one i think most people
suffer because they
they just
they don't focus
like you got to figure out i think the
big risk in this world is there's too
much of everything yeah
like you can sit and watch chess videos
100 hours a week and you'll never get
through all the chess videos
right there's there's too much of every
possible thing every too much of every
good thing so
figuring out
what you want to do and then
everything will suck up your time right
there's a hundred streaming channels to
binge watch on so you gotta guard your
time and then
train your body train your mind
and control who's around you
control
what surrounds you
so ultimately in a world where there's
too much of everything
then
you're just laser eyes it's like those
laser eyes you have to focus
on just a few of those things
yeah i mean
i got a thousand opinions we could talk
about and i could pursue a thousand
things but i don't expect to be
successful and i'm not sure that my
opinion in any of the 999 is any more
valid
than the leader of thought in that area
so
how about if i just focus upon one thing
and then uh and then uh deliver the best
i can in the one thing that's that's the
laser eye message
the rest get you distracted well how do
you achieve that do you do you find
yourself given where you are in life
having to say no a lot
or just focus comes naturally when you
just ignore everything around you so how
do you achieve that focus
i think it helps if people know what
you're focused on
so you everything about you just
radiates that people know people know
this
if they know what you're focused on then
you won't get
so many other things coming your way
if you
you know if you dolly
or if you if you flirt with 27 different
things then you're going to get
approached by people in each of the 27
communities right
you mentioned
getting a phd and
given your roots at mit do you think
there's there's all kinds of
journeys you can take to educate
yourself do you think a phd or
school is still worth it
or is there other paths through life
that is it worth it if you get to pay
for it is it worth it to spend the time
on it
the time
and the money is a big cost i i think um
time probably the bigger one right it
seems clear to me that the world wants
more specialists
it wants it wants you to be an expert in
and to focus on in one area
and it's punishing
uh generalist uh jack of all trades but
especially people that are generalists
in the physical realm because if you're
a specialist in the digital realm you
might very well you're the person with
700 000 followers on
twitter and you show them how to tie
knots
or you know you're the banjo player you
know with 1.8 million followers and when
everybody types banjo
it's you right yeah and so
the world wants people that that do
something well and then it wants to
stamp out 18
million
copies of them
and so that argues in favor of focus now
i mean the definition of a phd is is
someone with enough of an education that
they're capable of or have made i guess
i guess to get a phd technically you
have to have have uh done a dissertation
where you made a you know a seminal
contribution to the body of human
knowledge
right and and if you haven't done that
technically you know you have a master's
degree but you're not a doctor
so
if you're interested in any of the
academic disciplines
that a phd would be granted for
then i can see that being a reasonable
pursuit but there are many people that
are specialists
you know
you know the agimator
yeah yeah yeah
on youtube yeah yeah
he's the world's greatest chess
commentator yeah and i've watched his
career and he's got progressively better
and he's really good he's going to love
hearing this
yeah if the agile mate over here is this
i'm a big fan of the agitator i have to
cut myself off right because otherwise
you'll watch the entire paul morphy saga
for your weekend
but uh the point really is youtube is
full of experts who are specialists in
something
and they rise to the top of their
profession and
twitter is too and
the internet is
so i
i would advocate
that you figure out
what you're passionate about
and what you're good at
and you do focus on it
especially if
if the thing that you're doing can be
automated
the the problem is
you know back to that 500 000 algebra
teacher type comment the problem is if
it is possible to be automated then over
time someone's probably going to
automate it and
and
that that squeezes you know the state
space of everybody else it's like like
after the lockdowns it used to be there
like all these local bands that played
in bars and everybody went to the bar to
see the local band and then during the
lockdown you would have like these six
super groups and they would all get 500
000 or a million followers and all these
smaller local bands just got
no attention
at all well the interesting thing is one
of those 500 000 algebra teachers is
likely to be part of the automation so
it's like it's an opportunity for you to
think
where's my
um
field my discipline evolving into i
talked to a bunch of librarians just
having to be friends with librarians and
that's libraries will probably be
evolving and it's up to you as a
librarian to be one of the ones one of
the few that remain
in the rubble
if you're going to give commentary on
shakespeare plays i want you to
basically do it for every shakespeare
play like i want you to be the
shakespeare dude because once i once
just like lex you're like
i don't know what kind of
you're you're the deep thinking
podcaster right or you're you're the
you're the podcaster that goes after the
deep intellectual
conversations
and uh once i get comfortable with you
and i like you
then i start binge watching lex yeah but
but if you changed your format
yeah through 16 different formats so
that you could compete with 16 different
other personalities on youtube
you'd probably wouldn't beat any of them
right you would probably just kind of
sink into the you're you're the number
two or number three guy you're not the
number one guy in the format and i think
the
the the the algorithm
right the the twitter algorithm and the
youtube algorithms they really reward
the person that's focused on message
consistent
the world wants somebody they can trust
that's consistent and reliable
and they they kind of want to know what
they're getting into because
this is taken for granted maybe but
but
there's 10 million
people vying for every hour of your time
and so the fact that anybody gives you
any time at all
is a huge is amazing privilege right and
you should be thanking them
and and you should respect their time
it's interesting like everything you
said is very interesting but of course
from my perspective and probably from
your perspective
my actual life has nothing to do with
it's just being focused on stuff and uh
in my case it's like focus on
doing the thing i really enjoy doing
and being myself
and not caring about anything else like
i don't care about views or likes or
attention
and that just maintaining that focus is
the way from an individual perspective
you live that life
but yeah it does seem that there's
the world and technology is rewarding
the specialization and creating bigger
and bigger platforms for the different
specializations and
and that yeah and then that lifts all
both actually because the
specializations get better and better
and better at teaching people to do
specific things and they educate
themselves and it's just everybody gets
more and more knowledgeable and more and
more empowered
the reward for authenticity more than
offsets the specificity with which you
pursue your mission it's like that's
true like
yeah another way to say it is like
nobody wants to read advertising
like if you if you were to spend 100
million dollars advertising your thing
i probably wouldn't want to watch it
yeah
but that's fascinating yeah
we see the death of that yeah and so
that the commercial shows are losing
their audiences and the authentic
specialists or the authentic artists are
are gaining their audience
and that's a beautiful thing
speaking of deep thinking um
you're just a human your life ends
you've uh accumulated so much wisdom
so much money
but the right ends do you think about
that do you do you ponder your death
your mortality
are you afraid of it
when i go um all my assets will flow
into a foundation and the foundation's
mission is to make education free for
everybody forever
and
if uh if i'm able to contribute to the
creation of
of
a more perfect monetary system
then maybe that foundation will go on
forever
right the idea
the foundation of the idea so not just
the the
each of the foundations
it's not clear we're on the s-curve of a
mortal life yet like that's a biological
question and you ask that you know on
some of your other interviews a lot
i think that we are on the threshold of
um
of immortal life for ideas or mortal
life for certain institutions
or computer programs so if we can fix
the money then you can create um
a technically perfected endowment
and then
the question really is what are your
ideas what do you want to leave behind
and so if it's a park
then you endow the park right if it's if
it's free education you endow that if
it's
if it's some other
ethical idea right does it make you sad
that
there's something that you've
endowed
some very powerful idea
of digital energy that you put out into
the you help
put it into the world
and your mind your conscious mind
will no longer be there to
experience it
it's just gone forever
i'd rather think that the um
the thing that satoshi taught us is you
should do your part
during some phase of the journey and
then you should get out of the way
and yeah i think steve jobs said
something similar to that effect
in a very very famous speech one day
which is you know death is a natural
part of life and it makes way for the
next generation
and uh i i think
the goal is you upgrade the world right
you leave it a better place but you get
out of the way and uh
i think when um
when that breaks down
you know bad things happen
i think nature cleanses itself there's a
cycle of life
and speaking one of great people who did
also get out of the way is george
washington so hopefully when you get out
of the way nobody's bleeding you um
to death in hope of helping you
uh
what what do you think uh to do a bit of
a callback
what do you think is the meaning of this
whole thing what's the meaning of life
why are we here we talked about the rise
of human civilization it seems like
we're engineers at heart we'll build
cool stuff
better and better use of energy
channeling energy to be productive
why
what's it all for
they're getting metaphysical on me very
there's a beautiful boat to the left of
us like why do we do that this this boat
that sailed the ocean
then we build models of it to celebrate
great engineering of the past
to engineer is divine
you can make lots of arguments as while
we're here we're here we're they're here
to entertain ourselves or we're here to
to create something
that's beautiful or something that's
functional i think if you're an engineer
you entertain yourself by creating
something that's both beautiful and
functional
so i think all three of those things
it's entertaining but
it's ethical
you know you got to admire
you know the the first person that built
a bridge
crossing a chasm or
the first person to work out the problem
of how to get running water to a village
or the first person to figure out how to
you know
dam up a river
or mastered agriculture or
the guy that figured out you know how to
grow fruit on trees or crated orchards
you know and maybe one day had like 10
fruit trees he's pretty proud of himself
so that's functional
there is also something to that just
like you said that's just
beautiful it does get you closer to
um
like you said the divine something
when you when you step back and look at
the entirety of it
a collective of humans
using
a beautiful invention or creation or
just
just something about this instrument is
creating
a beautiful piece of music
that seems just right that's what we're
here for whatever the divine is it seems
like we're here for that that and i of
course love talking to you because uh
from the engineering perspective the
functional is ultimately the mechanism
towards the beauty
isn't there something beautiful about
about making the world a better place
for people that you love
your friends your family
or yourself
yeah
you know
when you think about the the entire arc
of
human existence
and you roll the clock back 500 000
years and you think about every struggle
of everyone that came before us and
everything they had to overcome in order
to put you here right now
you know
you kind of
you got to admire that right you got to
respect that
that's a heck of a gift they gave us
it's also
a heck of a responsibility
don't screw it up
if i dropped you 500 000 years ago i
said figure out steel refining
or or you know
fake
figure out rate silicon chips fab
reproduction or or whatever it is why or
fire
and so now we're here and i guess the
way you repay them is you fix everything
in front of your face you can
right that means
to to someone like elon it means get us
off the planet
right
to someone like me it's like i think
you know fix the energy in in the system
and that gives me hope michael this is
an incredible conversation you're an
incredible human it's a huge honor you
would sit down with me
thank you so much for talking today
yeah thanks for having me alex
thanks for listening to this
conversation with michael saylor to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with a few
words from francis bacon
money is a great servant
but a bad
master
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you